morning everybody
welcome to Edna
this is the committee orientation
first we're going to spend a while
getting to introduce ourselves
and then we will have a presentation
from the retirement system which is one
of the topics we deal with
followed by questions and after lunch we
will have a
performance audit of the Dental Board
which will give us a chance to meet the
performance Auditors and the office of
professional licensure and certification
which is another
which is one of the agencies we deal
with extensively
so
and general topics our office is outside
the room
everyone has a drawer there and is
there's also coffee help yourself if
you're going to be drinking a lot
contributions are expected
I'm Carol McGuire I'm in my eighth term
all but one on Edna and this is my
fourth time as chairman
uh
and so I have I know what what uh the
way I like to do things I can make
arrangements otherwise
so seating assignments are have been set
on the basis that we have
at least three people who have never
been on Edna before plus six newly
elected representatives I didn't want
them all clumped because
um
sitting next to somebody's way to learn
something
if you want if you really dislike your
seat let me know and I'll see if I can
change it
I'm passing around a pad I'd like to
know your preferred email and a phone
number I can at least leave messages on
um I tend to send out information by
email and the official Edna
list is not always looked at frequently
enough
so
hello my name is Shane sarway and I
represent
um Hillsborough County District 32 which
representative sherwa has graciously
volunteered to be our committee clerk
because representative scitec has moved
on to a different committee
uh
hi hi everyone I'm representative Jackie
groda I'm from Rye New Hampshire this is
good morning representative Jeff goli
representing Hillsboro 21 Manchester
good morning representative Kimberly a
bear representing Pelham New Hampshire
Hillsboro one and this is my first time
representative Tony lekkis uh
Hillsborough 38 that's Hudson and
Litchfield it's uh started my third term
Jason Gerhard uh first term
excited
Matt Santa nastasso is told me he's not
won't be able to be here today
so moving over to the other map
or one of the other thank you madam
chair my name is Matt Wilhelm uh
represent Hillsboro District 40 which is
Manchester Ward 1 3 10 11 and 12. so uh
representative goalie and I represent
good morning Chris true Rockingham 9
that's the big city of sand down New
Hampshire
uh I'm on my fifth term I've been on
transportation and criminal justice this
good morning
um representative Mike O'Brien from
Nashua district 10 which is basically
Ward 9 and uh time moves fast eight
uh Daniel Fitzpatrick Rochester first
time in partisan politics and my first
Peter Schmidt I represent award one in
Dover this is my
ninth term I think on Edna
Fred Davis wood for district
Hillsborough District 31 in Nashua uh
it's my first time on it's my second
term my first time I need DNA
good morning Glenn Bailey uh Stratford 2
which is Milton and Ward 5 of Rochester
this is my second time as a rep and the
representative Matt Simon little to New
Hampshire I represent Grafton district
one uh six towns in the greater
Littleton area this is my second term in
representative
thank you the one who came proofing in
late uh Diane schuett I represent
Pembroke
Merrimack District 12 and this is my
beginning my seventh term in the house
good morning you are
jeweled okay you are
ruled right there next between those two
if you would introduce yourself so we
hi my name is Sherry Gould and I'm
Merrimack District eight from one in New
Hampshire
happy to be here all right excellent I'd
also like to introduce our committee
researcher
who is Brad
um
great
foreign
our committee assistant is Carrie Morris
and she sits outside room 302 so it's
down the hall a bit but she will take
I'm
Edna normally has
established subcommittees that work on
specific topics
for example there will be one on
pensions and one on licensing
and this year we'll have one on
organization which will be focused on
oplc because
I happen to know we're going to be
getting a 90-page bill
and so we will need to look at that in
subcommittee so I'd be
interested in finding out who will be
who which of those committees you'd be
interested in serving on if you have a
strong preference
Representatives Simon lekka scrota and
shewitt will be the chairs of those
subcommittees
um assignment for pensions Lexus for
licensing
um
grotif for organization and chew it for
the other subcommittee which we'll be
picking up wherever necessary
so if anyone has a strong preference I'd
oh
wow
applied what you get to choose yeah well
I I mean I've made a draft but if but
I'm more than welcome deserves a lot of
people here I don't know well which is
which is unusual last term well we had a
couple of newbies but I met most of them
this term we've got a an assortment of
people and I don't know all of them
all right
other than that I think
that's mostly what I had so if anyone
would like to comment on why they chose
Edna I'd
I'd love to hear it or you have any
questions
it was under Bailey you're uh
be quiet yeah
I am representative McGuire Miss
chairman I was very interested whereas I
am a first-time representative to study
under a chair that has experience and
also keeps things very orderly
I was raised by an old Marine so I know
how to be short and to the point and I
heard you are too so I wanted to study
under you thank you all right thank you
very much
representative uh thank you I know we
don't necessarily know all the bills we
have but you have some uh a prediction
for what the schedule's going to look
like ah
days and Thursdays
I believe we are going to be getting
something like 70 bills there's only 19
in our possession right now
uh this Wednesday and Thursday I've
scheduled some of the
what I hope will be less contentious
ones
so we should be able to uh
as far as
um and then I don't know when the others
are coming other than that oplc
reorganization bill which will be coming
probably toward
the end of the month
I gave them a deadline of the 20th and I
and
as far as other things I'd like to
schedule executive sessions
relatively often
if we have a hearing and it's obvious to
most of us that we know what we want to
do with the bill I'll ask representative
Crowder to make a motion and we can exec
it right there
if it turns out that it is not obvious
um we can stop the executive session go
think about it some more but if if we
can get through some bills on Wednesday
representative Gould
hi sorry I was filling out the paperwork
when you asked about why I asked to be
on the committee so this is my first
time I was asked by the Democratic party
to run for rep which wasn't anything I
had thought about doing ever I'm an
independent a lifelong independent and
I'm an enrolled member of the Abernathy
the Mohegan band of the Abenaki Nation
so as I thought about it talked to my
husband about it there are you know
frequently bills not frequently
occasionally Bill's got me for this
committee that um my observation has
been that can be confusing and
um
perplexing for committee members the
public in general the Abenaki people
and so I thought that I could do some
good maybe that way to help
um just to help move things along
whatever so here I am thank you very
yeah
a large part of our work is totally
nonpartisan
I mean
how you organize things is not
um
isn't or shouldn't be a partisan
issue we sometimes get divided on
licensing but more often it if we have a
on a totally different issue than than
political party which I think is nice
there's some committees where
partisan issues Dominate and I don't and
that's hard to work with
okay
[Music]
good I'm sorry yeah Wilhelm
thanks Madam chair
um
I got my master's degree in in public
administration which is studying the
efficiency and effectiveness of of
government and so uh I'm excited to
think about ways to put that to work and
bring different perspectives to the
table
excellent that's very useful my my own
experience is entirely in private
business so I don't
which has different issues than the
public
all right
yes representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair
um so I had already served on a couple
of other committees in my first several
years in the legislature and when Terry
narelli became the speaker about
oh yeah
yeah no a long time ago
she I I didn't put down a preference uh
because I didn't want to go back to the
first committee I'd been on uh and I
left it up to her and she wanted to put
me on a special committee that this
committee the new members will be
unfamiliar with the name but it's an
important committee and it its work
comes up in this committee pretty often
in uh Terry narelli wanted to put me on
gel cards we call it the joint
legislative committee on administrative
rules and it has a lot of overlap with
with issues that are dealt with by Edna
so she put me on both of them
um and uh so representing McGuire is the
is the chair or will be shortly if she
isn't already
I think we elected you in your absence
last meeting uh not not because uh the
dominant rule is you know if the person
is out of the room you elect them chair
um but because she had been share of gel
car several times previously and it's
The house's term so so so we we uh we
serve on gel cry together already for
about eight years together I think uh
along with uh representative shuitt was
temporarily and maybe once again will be
on I think you're you're an alternate
you're on gilcar this term Diane
jelcar
okay representative groda I think is on
it's always a little bit of a scramble
at the beginning of a new session
because
new people come on all these standing
committees but there's a few uh
old war horses like representative
Schmidt and myself that are pretty
consistent on on that committee
representative Gerhard Madam chair I'm
just gonna sound kind of
um I'm serious though do we go on any
field trips in the sense of we're
supposed to be monitoring executive
departments and administration we
actually engage in
we have been known to
uh if you if something comes up that you
think would be a worthwhile feed field
trip let me know we've been to peas
we've been to the secure psychiatric
unit and
couple of other places it's not as good
as say Recreation
and
but but we do go to an occasional field
trip
because I went to what the county
orientation to the Merrimack Nursing
Home in the county jail it was pretty
interesting and informative so if that
is an option I would sign up for okay
thank you
Leo if you see something that you think
is merits a field trip will arrange for
it
um we
we also have this room on Fridays in
case of of sessions which are on
Thursday
but I hope not to schedule very much on
Fridays
the committee the subcommittee chairs
can use Fridays
and uh mornings I don't believe starting
too early because it's inconsiderate for
people that have to come a long way
but the uh
uh mornings and late afternoons are
available even on days we have a pretty
pretty hefty workload for uh
Madam chairs yes ma'am if I can just put
my two cents worth in uh for the benefit
of the new members of the committee
um I always describe Edna as a nuts and
bolts committee
we kind of look at all assets of state
government and I guarantee you new
members especially you will learn an
awful lot about how our state works that
you didn't know before thank you yes you
will learn about obscure and
probably deservedly obscure sections of
the State uh I've spent a lot of time
working on specifications for wood
stoves slaughterhouse regulation and
oh smoke alarms that was my first
introduction representative and I spent
way more time than I ever expected on
grease traps
a whole subcommittee on them that's it
yes we uh we get Oddball stuff
which is nice okay
um yes representative Schmidt
thank you ma'am chair uh and for those
of you who don't know the secure
psychiatric unit is located currently uh
for a
limited amount of time because the state
is building a new uh forensic Hospital
uh which will be available in a couple
of years but at the moment the secure
psychiatric unit is in the state prison
uh very unhappily for the last 35 or 36
years
and so a number of us have worked for
quite some time on getting it out of
there because it's not a good
arrangement
prevents it from being able to be
accredited and inputs uh Corrections
Officers in many cases
as overseers of people who are
mentally ill
and sometimes that doesn't work out well
so but
so I hope we will never have to go back
to the state prison again to to see the
secure psychiatric unit will do a tour
of New Hampshire hospital where the
forensic hospital will be built so but
that won't be for a couple years
so okay yeah
represent gold
I was being transparent and giving you
my most unique
feature for the committee but I should
say that my professional career was in
child welfare and in what child welfare
oh okay and I worked I ran residential
programs under contract for dcyf but
then I worked for dcyf in um
on the information system I was the
person who interpreted Social Work
practice to the computer programmers for
Bridges the hated bridges in fact on 911
I was here at a hearing talking about
how we store data uh so in my role in
dcyf of course I'm working in the state
office I was trained about the whole
sausage making process and and um and
how laws become policy and policy become
procedure and my role was most
frequently in working on the procedure
for the dcyf component
and um I really hope we do get to go to
the psychiatric secure unit to visit my
grandson is there and I haven't been
able to visit him so I'm very interested
in in working on any of those issues
Madam chair and I wanted you to under to
know I had those kinds
excellent well if you're familiar with
it we're I've seen that we're going to
be getting a bunch of
bills on open source software and other
requirements so
no anyone knowing anything about that
will be valuable there's a large numbers
well thank you all for being brief and
open
and since we've got a minute or two I'll
introduce our next next speaker we had
it's Mr Marty Carlin who is the public
information officer for the
State Retirement System he's a frequent
visitor
and is the best source of information on
the retirement system so we will he'll
give us a short presentation and then be
oh
excellent we haven't met yet
thank you madam chair
um again for the record my name is Marty
Carlin uh representing the New Hampshire
retirement system I'm here with our
executive director Jane Goodwin today
and we'll be walking through a slide
presentation you have a copy of it in
the folder the nhrs folder on your
um at your spots on the table I'm glad
to answer questions along the way and as
well as at the end and obviously
follow-ups as we go through the session
um I think you'll be sick of me in about
two or three weeks with the number of
retirement related bills introduced in
the house this year along with the slide
deck there's some other a couple of
other pieces of information in the
in the packet these are some documents
called nhos now you know which try to
put in as plain English as we can some
of the more complicated topics uh we
hear about from members and lawmakers
and employers you know
pension liability uh colas things like
that so that's just the supplemental
information and it's also a fact sheet
that we're also going to be dropping off
at the house
um clerk's office so you may get a
second one in your mailbox in a couple
of days as well
um with that I'll turn it over to
director Goodwin to get us started thank
you
thank you very much Marty for getting us
started and thank you very much chair
McGuire for welcoming us to your
committee we look forward to
um presenting a great deal of
information about nhrs and how it works
before I do that though I would like to
turn to two of my colleagues who have
recently joined nhrs
um Marie Mullen is our Director of
Finance you may recognize her she used
to be the Director of Finance for the
and then secondly on her right is
Reynold Levesque he is our new Chief
investment officer he's filling the very
large shoes that Larry Johansen left
when he retired as our director of
Investments and Reynold has been with
with us since the beginning of October
so we've got a lot of new faces um from
nhrs but our mission and vision Remains
the Same
we do have a formal presentation to give
you but as Marty noted you know please
feel free to jump in I'm sure to the
newer members of the committee
um you're going to be learning a lot of
jargon which you haven't been exposed to
before and nhrs like every other entity
in the state has a lot of its own jargon
a lot of it has to do with either
Investments or Actuarial matters and so
if we're not doing a good job defining
things as we go along please just say
say you'd like some clarification
you can get a little bit closer
absolutely thank you very much for that
feedback
so on page two of the presentation you
will see the map of all the different
areas we're going to be touching on
today
um brief overview Marty's going to walk
through membership and benefits then
I'll talk about Investments Marty will
go back and discuss contributions and
funding and legislation and then all
providing a wrap-up summary at the end
and at the end of the materials there's
a number of appendices that I'll be will
be referring to during our presentation
which have a lot of good background
information for you
so let's jump in page three
so nhrs is a contributory multi-employer
defined benefit plan and was established
in 1967 contributory means that the
members the employees make contributions
and so our members make a substantial
proportion of the total contributions
that are received for their benefits
so nhrs in addition to providing a
retirement benefit also provides
disability and death benefits as well as
post-retirement medical subsidy to
eligible members and beneficiaries
and once members attain eligibility
which is referred to as vesting they can
receive a guaranteed lifetime pension
and the pension benefits are funded
through the employee as well as the
employer contributions and the
investment income
and traditionally the investment returns
have been have provided the majority of
the monies that go and pay our members
their benefits and their beneficiaries
so if you could turn to page
four of your
packet
it shows that nhrs is a component unit
of state government overseen by a Board
of Trustees
and the Board of Trustees has a role and
asked as the independent investment
committee and they're both both groups
are fiduciaries
the legislature that is you you are our
plan sponsor
and our staff implements the statutes
and rules and policies but in addition
to state law we also have to be
concerned with federal law that's where
the Internal Revenue code comes in we
are what's known as a qualified pension
plan that means that the contributions
that go into the plan are on a pre-tax
basis to the to the members and the
investment income that accrues on those
earnings during the employees working
career are not taxed until such time as
the members retire and receive their
pension benefits so being a qualified
plan is a big deal and as serious tax
consequences and that's why we always
are concerned that we are following the
Internal Revenue code as well as New
Hampshire state law
then there's also the New Hampshire
Constitution Article 36a
which states that the funds are for the
exclusive purpose of providing benefits
for our members
and it requires the board to certify
employer rates based on sound Actuarial
practice the board just did that this
summer they just certified the rates for
fiscal years 24 and 25 and Marty later
on in the presentation will be will be
discussing what those rates are
and it also requires and this is the
hard part is that the employers have to
pay the rates that have been certified
you've probably heard
um either as a legislator or even as a
citizen that there are many states in
the country that in the in the U.S that
have large unfunded pension liabilities
the main reason why those states have
those liabilities is because they've
never paid the contributions that were
required so examples of that are New
Jersey New Jersey is what New Jersey
Illinois and Kentucky are the poster
children for not paying contributions
fortunately New Hampshire has been
disciplined and makes those
contributions
the next slide is Slide Five
and so one of the key fiduciary duties
for our trustees is to make sure that
our plan is adequately funded
and this equation is the Hallmark
equation of pension plans contributions
plus investment income
over time must equal benefit payments
plus the expenses
and the reason why this all works is the
compounding of interest income and
dividend income on the Investments
Albert Einstein the famous mathematician
rightly said that compounding interest
is the eighth wonder of the world and
that's what makes our pension plan and
all other pension plans work it's
getting the money in on time
having a good investment
plan and executing that plan
as of June 30 2022 our trust fund assets
the next slide is slide six and this
shows how our assets have grown steadily
over time
as you can see we did have a bit of a
dip
um well actually before the slide with
the
2008-2009 and we've been CL our assets
have been climbing steadily after that
and these assets that are reflected here
these are the fair market value of the
assets our actuaries when they present
information and present different
metrics they like to use a smoothed
value of our assets because as you can
see on this Slide the numbers
can jump up and down a bit as you can
see the precipitous
um declined that we had in this past
fiscal year which was a very challenging
year in Investments
and at this point I will turn things
thank you
again
um so slide seven just some some recent
nhrs initiatives
um we're the system is in the midst of a
multi-year project to upgrade its core
pension Administration system basically
the brain of the retirement system that
calculates all the benefits and and does
all that our current system was put in
in 2003 four so it you know anyone who
deals with software or large
applications realizes that that's
extremely elderly so we're moving to a
newer
um you know more more secure web-based
version of that that platform so that
that's been a significant internal piece
as we as we head towards the end of this
year where I hope to be switching over
um cyber security enhancements and
training has have been a priority for a
number of years and that that's ongoing
again anybody who reads a headline
realizes you know different security
threats and and Bad actors out there in
the world and we've got two things that
a lot of people people want a money and
personal information so we work very
hard to train the staff and also to
protect us with technological solutions
and Human Solutions to to try to prevent
uh something like that from affecting us
um
enhanced education and Outreach we've
always done member education we've been
trying we've been adding uh different
programs targeted for members in
different stages of their careers
additional employer
presentations on different niches and
public education typically what we do in
the first year of a session is after we
do this presentation for any committee
who'll hear us in the house or Senate um
you know we open this up for you know
employers and members and retirees to
come and we'll give them the same
presentation over at the office in a few
weeks so
um you know we try to we think that you
know there's a lot of
um maybe misconceptions or
misunderstanding of how the retirement
system works so we want to be out front
you know defining what the facts are so
people can at least have reasonable
disagreements based on on the underlying
facts uh and then uh two it's just
celebrated its second anniversary but we
created a contact center uh for incoming
calls and emails a couple years ago uh
that's been very successful in cutting
down on people you know being left in
voicemail and more on hold uh things
like that
um the folks there are trained to answer
probably was about 80 ish or 90 of the
questions on the first call rather than
having a transfer so that's that's some
of the things we've been up to
the next slide is a historical slide and
you know one thing is you know the past
is always close and there are a lot of
decisions made in the past that are
affecting where we are right now as a
retirement system
um and honestly I could go back and do
four slides going back to the 70s if
you'd like but I'm not going to do that
right now for this committee but since
2007 over the last 15 or so years
there's been some major changes to nhrs
uh beginning in 07 the legislature
changed the way the actuaries calculate
our funding and our liabilities and our
rate I'll go into a little history about
what happened in the 90s when we get
into the employer rates but essentially
this was a reset to the to the most
commonly and currently only acceptable
way to calculate our funding uh there
was a sort of a method in place prior to
that that under charged employers
essentially but that was corrected by
the legislature in 07.
um through legislation the independent
investment committee was created in 09
previously the board had done uh you
know the the investment nitty-gritty of
you know hiring and firing and
monitoring managers and we the
legislature created a um
separate committee that had non-trustee
members as well as a couple of trustees
and all of the members have to have
significant experience in uh Finance or
institutional investment so we got a
group of professionals together and
they've actually grown the fund uh quite
well over the uh the last 13 years and
ngm's got a slide about that later on
um 2010 this was enacted in 07 but a
30-year closed amortization of our
pension liabilities and we'll talk about
liabilities a lot throughout this
presentation but
um the legislature put a we're going to
start paying this debt off now and it's
going to be done by 2039 before it was a
rolling amortization so you're really
never paying it off you're almost
refinancing every two years just rolling
the debt forward and forward so the
close the amortization was a big one
um and in 2011 the board lowered our
investment assumption
from eight and a half to seven and three
quarters uh there were subsequent
reductions over the last 10 years to the
current 6.75 this is a reflection both
of you know sort of the reality of
markets things were a lot more volatile
than they were even 10 years ago
investment wise and fixed income
investing with interest rates
historically low for so long uh you know
there was there was rebalancing and you
couldn't count on your fixed income to
bring in you know five six percent like
you could uh you know in the 90s and the
early 2000s so that was sort of a
recognition of
you know what a realistic number would
be
um 2011 hb2 there's a there's a there's
a house bill too every two years it's
the Budget Trailer bill but uh this 2011
hb2 and contained you know about 25
pages of changes to nhrs
um it was in a standalone Senate bill
that was vetoed by the governor and
reinserted into hb2 but essentially this
increased member contributions reduced
benefit accruals for some current and
future members uh changing the
composition of our board eliminated the
state subsidy for local employer
retirement costs and and many other uh
changes that folks will be talking to
about this this session with some
legislation coming up
um so that was by far the biggest change
since the system was created back in the
60s the the changes in uh 2011.
um because of the significance of those
changes the number of
court cases were brought by affected
parties and the Supreme Court
essentially uphold the legislature's
purview to prospectively change you know
benefit Provisions uh for members
um you know uh in a series of decisions
that were reduced uh released over
between 14 and 16.
again we talked about the changes to the
assumed rate of return and in 2017 there
was something called the decennial
commission the first Commission of this
type met in 07 there'll be another one
in 2027 it's a statutory committee and
chair Maguire was on it
um
and um
it it it's charged with looking at the
long-term viability of the retirement
system and looking back at the last 10
years and at where we are going forward
uh that that is not just the legislative
committee there were members retirees
members of the public and employer
Representatives on there as well and
that that committee met through the fall
of 17 and issued a fairly lengthy report
that is available on the general court
website under special committees and we
have a copy on our site if anybody's
ever interested in a link
representative I have a hard copy know
how to get it to you
um so that's sort of the lay of the land
of where we've been over the last 10
years
um and I'm going to switch gears to
slide nine for brief this overview just
a second are there uh any there aren't
any questions there will be a quiz yeah
representative
thank you madam chair
um going back to slide four I'm just
curious about the makeup of both the
Board of Trustees and the investment
committee
um
what how are those members appointed
the um there's an actual in the appendix
the appendices there's a list of the
membership uh in the back
um the Board of Trustees is four members
of the public uh nominated by the
governor confirmed by the council uh
there's four active member employees one
from each of the four member groups
employee teach teacher police and fire
and those are nominated by employee
organizations and then they go through
the governor and Council the employers
have basically the same layout the
counties the municipalities the school
districts and the state has one employer
representative and then the treasurer is
ex-officio is the 13th member of the
board the iic all are confirmed by um
governor and Council uh the the board
chair names of the trustee members of
the investment committee and the others
um you know again are non-trustees so
they come from outside and that's page
35 and 36.
thanks representative Aber
thank you Mr chairman
my question may be more nuts and bolts
than it needs to be and if it is just uh
just let me know
okay thank you um so my question is with
regard to the plan
is there a reason why there's more of a
calf plan instead of an after-tax plan
for our retirees
in other words with tax rates going up
higher and higher and higher these
people are contributing after tax money
sorry before tax money meaning that as
it grows in as the tax base grows that
they will be they won't be able to
uh representative a bear employees pay a
fixed percentage of salary toward the
pension there are also
other plans where they can make pre and
post tax contributions if they wish
those are all voluntary and
not under the purview of the retirement
system thank you
in general terms too the pensions are
lower than what they're making as an
active employee so they may be in a
lower bracket if they're taxed on the
post retirement income yeah
representative true
thank you madam chair on slide eight it
shows uh the reduced rate of return
being lowered a number of times
what does that how does that affect the
retirement system the reduced rate
basically the member contributions are a
fixed amount coming in it's a statutory
rate that the members pay in and the
other two revenue streams are employer
contributions and investment income so
if the expectation is investment income
is is decreasing that's going to
because we use that rate of return to
calculate what our unfunded liability is
and so the lower the assumed rate of
return the higher the unfunded liability
and as Marty said that's what drives the
need to increase the employer
contribution rates because they have to
be paid we we are in the process of
amortizing the bulk of our unfunded
liability within a 30-year period
thank you
it also makes them more accurate and
more likely to be achieved which is why
they're being lowered representative
Gerhart thank you madam chairman uh
woman
um just quick question I can research my
own time but what was hap what happened
prior to 67 did the state not have
retirement system it had four separate
Retirement systems for police fire
teachers and state employees they had
separate board separate funding methods
they Consolidated them
there is an assignment
thank you madam chair
um just a quick question on the ual
um where is that at the present moment
thank you um I'm wondering if this is
the proper time for Mr Carlin to
describe uh why the municipalities are
involved in the retirement system
as a follow-on to representative
gerhard's question yes that would be
appropriate
yeah the the in the the predecessor
systems which were all set up probably
in the sort of 1938 to 42 range
um you know full they were referred to
as permanent police men in permanent
firemen because back then that's what
they were but
um so any municipality who had teachers
police or fire you know could contribute
for their full-time employees into this
system the Employee Retirement System
was more of a state Employee Retirement
System but municipalities had the option
to join and that carried over into uh
when we were Consolidated I'm not sure
how many municipalities were in the
predecessor systems back in the 40s and
50s but it was originally a state
employees retirement system I think
that's what it was referred to
um so so and that that's carried over in
in our our law RSA 100a if you uh
participation in the retirement system
is mandatory for full-time
permanent police fire and teachers and
for employees of the state and and for
municipalities in which they've opted to
join the retirement system
um some communities the smaller towns up
north may have never had full-time
employees or maybe never joined uh some
may offer a supplemental retirement plan
some may not the city of Manchester has
its own city employees
retirement system that's been around for
a long time so Manchester teachers
police and fire are in the system but
employees are not Nashua DPW I know
we've got a few natural folks on it have
their own retirement plan as well but
most of the other Municipal employers
that aren't in nhrs do more of like sort
of the defined contribution route or
nothing
with that does that answer your question
representative or okay
representative thank you
um if you are going to address this
later than presentation you can defer
answering it but uh could you explain
how we ended up with an unfunded
liability we'll defer that but that's
representative
thank you madam chair Mr Collins I
wonder if you could in 1967 the
enticement for uh all the municipalities
was you know you want them to buy into
this particular system and it was
theoretically a promise that the state
would pay 35 percent and over the years
from past legislators that has dropped
down can you tell us the current amount
amount that the state contributes to the
municipalities and how in addition to
that the uaal affects that to the
municipalities
well the the to answer your second
question first the uaal is part of the
employer contribution rate and any of
paying down the liability is is
completely on the employer side the
members are pre-funding their own
benefit but that money is going towards
their benefit so the employers pay the
bulk of the UN pay all of the unfunded
and we've got some slides that'll show
how larger percentage that is of the
total rate later on in the presentation
uh currently there is no State pre
contribution offset for um teachers
police and fire as representative Brian
said it had been a a 35 percent for a
number of decades last year there was a
bill for a one-time reimbursement of
seven and a half percent of local
teacher police and fire contributions
out of the general fund
um you know that but you know that was a
one-time reimbursement representative
O'Brien you will be pleased to know that
there is a bill this year to resume that
contribution and it has been vacated
from this committee and sent directly to
finance it doesn't affect the retirement
system because
it just
defines who pays the amount set by the
retirement system so we're not going to
be dealing with it thank God
although very disappointed but thank you
madam chair I thought you'd like to know
because you were you you won the I think
it was six pis on that in 2020. Madam
chair when you're good you're good
anyway yes you're the expert on that one
okay sorry about that any uh other
questions at this point
all right representative Gould
I'm terrible with acronyms my husband's
been quizzing me helping me with e-dna
and I've got that one down can you tell
me what ual stands for unfunded
Actuarial accrued liability okay thank
you or unfunded liability for short
all right so we'll jump into benefits
which is a page slide nine and again as
there are a lot of new members for the
folks who are here they've had these
some of these terms tattooed on their
their wrists for many years but we have
two membership groups in the retirement
system group one consists of employees
and teachers uh in group two consists of
police and fire and under the police
umbrella the definition definition also
includes State and County correctional
employees uh generally speaking
um
so we have 461 participating employers
the state of New Hampshire is is
obviously the largest with about 22 or
23 percent of the total membership
um but we have uh large employees like
you know Nashua or and very small
employees like public libraries housing
authorities water districts up north you
know Mutual Aid compacts things like
that so there's a real gamut in the
number of the size of our employers
um the next slide slide 10 just shows a
breakdown of active and retired members
and beneficiaries by group
um as you'll see there on slide 10
employees are about half of the active
membership and a little bit less than
half of the retired membership teachers
make up 35 to 37 percent and police and
fire combined make up about 12 percent
of the actives in a slightly higher
percentage of their retired uh
population there are younger retirement
ages for group two police and fire so
that's why the the numbers are a little
higher there and below the chart it just
shows the active you divided those 48
687 members together you'd get a 46 year
old who make with 11.4 years of service
and the average retiree and the
aggregate is 71.7 average benefit of 21
862 per year that's going to differ
between the four member groups and we do
have a slide coming up that will show
on slide 11
you know last fiscal year our fiscal
year ends June 30th like the state and
we paid out 914 million dollars in
pension benefits so we'll be able to
boast a billion dollar payroll within a
year or two
um the way we're tracking and in the
same period we paid out 43.8 million in
what's called a medical subsidy payment
this is an insurance premium offset that
goes um to reduce the out-of-pocket uh
Insurance costs for eligible members
getting insurance from the employer they
retired from this is a closed program
and nobody's
um you know there's only a handful of
people who are working and still
eligible in group two but it is it is
another uh benefit that the legislature
granted uh back in the 80s and had and
closed down several years past and about
80 percent of our retirees live in New
Hampshire so that 914 million most of
that money stays in the state economy
they're paying their property taxes with
it they're going out to eat and paying
their rooms and meals tax you know
they're hiring Somebody To You know
clean their furnace whatever so so there
is an economic you know besides the cost
you threw municipality through property
taxes for retirement there's also a
positive economic impact from these
benefits staying in New Hampshire uh the
next slide
shows the benefits by County uh paid
last year so obviously as you might
expect the southern Counties have the
larger population of retirees but even
co-ops you know retirees up there get
22.6 million dollars which is
um
um slide 13. I'm talking about the how
the benefits are determined we have four
different types of retirement and
sometimes when changes are proposed to
these
um you know the committee will look at
different different modifications but
the four types are Service retirement
which is the most common that's you know
you're old enough you put in your
paperwork and You Begin collecting your
benefit most uh of our members go out on
service retirement we also have
disability benefits job related and
non-job-related that people can qualify
for
oh
thank you Marty before we get away from
it uh I want to come back to the thing
about paid by County uh do I understand
correctly that uh the the figures don't
really have anything to do with anything
other than where the people live or
getting the benefit it doesn't say
anything about where they ever worked
it's where they live yes okay
thank you I guess you'll notice that
Rockingham County has less than one
might expect
probably because it's cheaper to move up
thank you madam chair
I see on slide number 12 that it's it's
where everybody lives but
and I did kind of preview through the
slides is there any comparison where
firemen and police across the
across the border because of some of our
benefits uh is there any state
comparison in your presentation today
no uh we we just have our own data so we
wouldn't be able to track that to how
many New Hampshire residents are working
in you know Methuen or wherever things
like that we wouldn't have that data to
track
thank you
okay representative O'Brien thank you
madam chip would I be in order to assist
the representative in answering her
point
oh sure
so that you know I'm also a vice
president of the board of Baltimore and
the national we do have a hard time in
hiring and uh it is one of the old
adages of you know the job May stink
particularly being the copper or a
fireman but the pennies were always good
and there has been somewhat of a Down
crease so there is some problems there's
also many other different things that Mr
Collins is not going to answer but
today's generation is different too and
don't really seek that type of work like
they used to
please
maybe representative O'Brien we could
take that conversation offline later we
do have some challenges
yes there are many challenges in hiring
public employees these days
thank you okay thank you so uh back to
slide 13 I talked about service and
disability retirement there's also an
early retirement option folks can begin
collecting before their full retirement
age at a permanent permanently reduced
amount not a lot of people do that but
it is there invested deferred retirement
this is where someone has worked at
least 10 years with a retirement system
employer and they stop working for that
employer or for a participating employer
before they reach their retirement age
if they keep their contributions with
the retirement system they can come back
to us when they age into retirement
eligibility and Collective benefit based
on the prior service
so those are the four types there are
different benefit Provisions for group
one and group two that's always been the
case uh since the the plan was set up uh
and since 2011 there have been different
benefit Provisions based on the vested
status and higher date of the member in
each group for more than a decade now we
would refer to people who are vested
prior to January 1st of 2012 members who
are in the system prior to July 1st of
2011 but not yet vested on January 1st
of 12th and anyone hired on or after
July 1st of 2011 as part of our pension
upgrade and also because it no longer
makes sense this far out to keep doing
that we're actually going to be sort of
renaming the benefits as tier a b and c
um there so it may be an easier
shorthand way for people to save those
mouthfuls going forward we roll that
nominclature out to employers already
and we're going to be sharing with the
membership and we will get at the
opportunity to delve into these
differences because I've seen at least
three bills that appear to be
affecting them
and regardless of of what group you're
in or what tier the most of the pension
benefits are determined by statutory
formulas so
um that look at creditable service how
long someone has worked in months and
years uh average final compensation
which is going to be their highest three
or their highest five years of
um income depending on which tier
they're in and then a benefit multiplier
and that does seven different
multipliers in group two and there's
there's two in group one so you know
there's a lot of distinctions in there I
mean essentially what the um you know
there's a lot there and as
representative McGuire said there's
several bills looking at tweaking some
of that so
I'll save you some time for the details
there but we'll we certainly will
probably delve into them uh slide 14
this is the the site I referenced a
little earlier average benefit by group
um
employee teacher police and fire
um the benefit formulas are generate a
higher benefit for police and fire but
also these these members don't pay into
Social Security nor does their employer
so that's part of the recognition for
the benefit structure I think the job is
also a recognition for uh the retirement
eligibilities and things like that
um one thing you see with oh this
question no actually it's a comment one
thing you'll notice is that nearly all
police and fire have full careers a
significant number of employees do not
work full careers for a participating
employer
they may work 10 well at least 10 and
then go somewhere else or they may spend
10 years working for the state and going
on somewhere so there's a lot more
turnover in group one than in group two
where if they there is turnover
they'll go from the
Epson Police Department to the
Manchester Police Department where
there's more opportunities or something
like that
yeah absolutely those Public Safety and
teaching jobs seem to be sort of
callings their vocations you know and um
you know we are we see at least half of
our teachers retire with more than 25
years many with 30 and um you know
police and fire uh similarly that the
firefighters tend to work a couple years
longer on average uh in terms of years
of service they retire with than police
that that's been a trend for a while
well I think everybody that's new to
this has to understand that
um you can be a teacher until you're
quite far along in age police and fire
are a young man's game you really don't
want to be a police officer chasing
somebody down an alley at 55 years of
age or running up and down a ladder at
55 years of age
so they they have much shorter careers
by physical necessity
thank you representative Schmidt thank
you uh slide 15 just shows sort of a
breakdown
um by amount
um you know our average you know the
average annual benefit is is a little
bit under 22 but I'm more than a quarter
of our folks receiving a benefit now get
a benefit annual benefit of under 10 000
64 under 25 and 93 under 50 000 a year
so you know typically this is the time
of year I we get requests for you know
pension lists you know from different
Outlets
foreign
what's that
I'm sorry I didn't mean to interrupt I
said is that a food bank contribution
uh we don't know
um
yeah the other point is that the the
SE averages also include people who
retired 50 odd years ago yeah at that
time a ten thousand dollar pension was
do you have the information on what the
pensions of people currently retiring
are
I yes I can I can I can follow up and
send that chart to the committee we run
that every year
um for uh for finance so new it's new
retirements over the past 10 years what
thank you madam chair I refer to through
you to uh Mr Colin would this be the
proper time to discuss what a caller is
to new members or or is it yeah am I
getting ahead of you you were right on
yeah thank you so much perfect timing
that that old segue in so again just on
that slide 50 and the last point is less
than two percent of our retirees see an
average benefit of over 75 000 a year so
that that's you know
um you know that just just how that
breakdown
what legislating for the minority
sometimes can
debates can center around that and it's
really a small amount of people
um so slide 16 uh cola's cost of living
adjustments
um this is something that
um is not automatic in New Hampshire the
legislature has to Grant a cost of
living adjustment either a permanent
addition or a one-time retire repayment
if if um they choose to do so the last
Cola which you know permanent addition
to the pension was a one percent one and
a half percent increase on the first
fifty thousand of anyone's benefit that
was granted in 2019 and took effect in
FY 21 so July of 2020 so that was a
permanent addition of a maximum of 450
dollars you know or less depending on
your pension up up to that first 50 last
year
um there was a one-time 500 payment for
anyone who was retired more than five
years and I had a benefit of under
thirty thousand so that that was about
22 23 000 members it was about 11
million that the state paid um from
general fund to do that the Cola in 2019
was
um not pre-funded so that was added to
the employer contribution rates going
forward for the next 20 years so uh yes
we're praying for that every day every
uh time we get our tax bills
representative schuette yes uh could you
please tell the committee the last time
prior to 2019 that employees got a a
full Cola absolutely it was 2010.
and they're one of the handouts in the
folder is about Kohl's and I think it
has a chart going back either 20 or 25
years on on colas so for reference
that's there
yeah so we have a cost of living
increase Bill also so we'll get to dig
into the nuts and bolts of that one
okay and with that
um it's Jan's turn again to talk about
thank you very much Marty so if you
could please turn to page 17
um it discusses the Board of Trustees as
well as the independent investment
committee
so the board has a couple of very
important responsibilities in addition
to the setting the employer contribution
rates that we discussed earlier they
also improved the investment policy
which includes the asset allocation and
for those of you who are involved in the
investment world it's asset allocation
is the single most important determinant
of investment performance
and so our board as well as our
independent investment committee spend a
great deal of time on making these
important decisions because they have
such a strong impact on our investment
performance the board is also
responsible for hiring the investment
consultant
and on page 35 you can see all of the
current members of our Board of Trustees
all 13 of them
and then we also have the independent
investment committee which as Marty
discussed earlier was created by the
legislature and became effective in
January 1st of 2009 that is made up of
six people there are five of them
um two of which are from directly from
our board and then another three that
are appointed by the governor with the
consent of the the council and then
there is a sixth member who is a
non-voting member who is there to
represent the plan members
and those people the different committee
members are shown on page 36 in the
appendices
so the independent investment committee
recommends investment policy to the
board and they also oversee the
administration of the investment program
within the board's policies
so part of that includes hiring the
investment service providers which are
the different individual money managers
as well as important service providers
like the cus the custodial bank which is
where the individual Securities actually
live on electronic spreadsheets as well
as the different investment managers
that make the buy and sell decisions for
the different
stocks or bonds that are in our
Investment Portfolio
every year the independent investment
committee with staff prepares a
comprehensive annual investment report
the care which is approved by the board
so if you could turn to page 18 please
and this gets it gets a bit more into
the nitty-gritty on the Investments so
as I said earlier the asset allocation
is the pr the predominant determinant of
investment performance and so we use
different strategies to make our
investments work and so the invest the
iic the independent investment committee
regularly reviews strategy with our
staff as well as our outside consultant
and nhrs because we're a pension plan we
are different than you all as
independent
investors our time Horizon is this is
more than 25 years if not actually in
infinite because we are going we are a
Perpetual organization and as long as
New Hampshire is here and has employees
either for the state or the individual
cities and counties we need to be
providing
retirement benefits for those employees
so that means that our iic can have a
very different time perspective on
making Investments than you as an
individual who is concerned about your
own lifetime where can say there we
consider the lifetimes of all of our
members both current and future so that
makes some Investments appropriate for
us that might not be appropriate for
and part of that Balancing Act is met is
managing our risk and liquidity we have
to make sure that we always have enough
cash on hand to make that monthly
payroll to our
retirees and the beneficiaries and we
also need to know how much cash we can
afford to lock up in Investments that
have a very long time Horizon and are
not as liquid as Investments such as the
S P 500 where we can have daily
liquidity
so our investment staff manages a
diversified portfolio among different
types of assets and so you can see on
this chart the different broad
categories of assets that we have both
their target amounts as well as their
actual allocations so we have starting
in the
upper right hand quadrant of these
circles we have domestic equities so
these are the stocks that you're
probably the most familiar with stocks
such as the ones that are in the you
know the the Dow Jones Industrial which
is the 30 largest companies as well as
the S P 500 the standard and Poor's 500
largest companies by capitalization side
as well as other smaller and mid-cap U.S
stocks
then going down clockwise on this chart
we also have non-us equities so
we have stocks in companies in all
around the world
so that we can find the best investment
return for our members
keeping going around clockwise the green
area is fixed income also referred to as
bonds so those are another important
part of our Investment Portfolio and
then we also have a sizable amount of
our portfolio invested in real estate
and then going all the way up to the top
we also have alternative Investments
that's the red area and the examples of
that are private Equity Funds as well as
private debt funds so we have a wide
variety of assets because
diversification is important because
typically what happens when one part of
the portfolio does very well in other
part does not so we always have to
balance that
if you could please turn to page 19
do you have any INF pardon me do you
have any information on
the Retirement Systems investments in
China
um we do have some investments in China
but we do own some stocks in Chinese
companies but I do not have the exact
amount and but we can get that
information for you I just finished
reading the book uh the end of the world
is just
Beginning by Peter Zahn and I highly
highly
recommend it and I'm just concerned that
investments in U.S firms with a large
Market in China and also the Chinese
companies
which are really
owned by the CCP that those in
Investments may become a very risky in
the future going forward thank you madam
chair yes the uh the
retirement system investment committee
evaluates Source risk and I know that
they
divested a significant number of Russian
stocks over the last couple of years
yeah there was a bill last year uh
requiring any share nhrs to divest um
directly held China Holdings and and we
did
um that was it directly held Investments
was I think under a hundred thousand or
right in that range it was a very small
piece of the portfolio there's obviously
if we're maybe in funds where they have
exposure in China but direct Investments
were very low at the time
as I referred to earlier on page 19
um fiscal year 22 was a very challenging
year to be in the investment world and
our one-year return reflects that we had
a net loss of 6.1 percent however it was
better than what our Benchmark was which
was a loss of 9.3 percent
the three-year return was 7.1 percent
The Five-Year return was 7.2 percent and
the longer year returns were were higher
and the important thing is that what we
as important as any one year is what
we're always looking at is how does this
compare to our assumed rate of return
are we achieving that over the long term
and with our long-term assumed rate of
return of 6.75 percent you can see by
looking at all of these different
returns for different time periods we
and so far this fiscal year to date our
annualized return through the end of
November was 3.5 percent and I've asked
Reynold if he can guarantee that we'll
do similarly in the rest of the fiscal
actually I don't think you'd want to
limit him to three and a half percent oh
that was for the first six months I won
another three and a half but you're
right there's no upward
and our performance relative to our
peers has also been strong both last
year as well as over
um the past decade
page 20. so I mentioned earlier about
why our actuaries like to smooth
everything over a five-year period
because
assets vary dramatic can vary year by
year and investment return for any given
year can show a great deal of ups and
downs and that is exactly what you see
on this slide you we see
um
performance from 2007 through 2022 and
we use on the left hand side of that
chart you see that
the lower performance that was caused
during the great financial crisis that
affected not just the United States but
the entire world and as well as the
bounce back after that in the next two
fiscal years and then you see the ups
and downs over time and so that's why
our actuaries smooth things out
over a five-year period and that's what
that Gray Line is that's the smoothed
return on our investments and the reason
why we want to do that is when we set
the employer contribution rates when the
board does that every two years the
actuaries calculate everything based on
the smoothed rates because otherwise you
could see how
we would have wildly swinging employer
contribution rates if they were just
based on the last fiscal Year's
investment performance and our employers
prefer to have
employer contributions rates that are
steady over time rather than swinging
dramatically up or down well they
wouldn't mind dramatically swinging down
but they do not like those big increases
just quick question two questions
actually
um do you are you allowed to invest in
like gold silver and crypto and do you
that's first one okay um
we our current investment policy does
not allow us to invest in commodities
we did have a very minor exposure to the
crypto industry through some of our
private Equity Funds it was a total of
and then the second question would be
follow-up I'm sorry can I please follow
up please
with the performance when you exceed
performance expectations is there some
kind of compensation or anything paid to
State Employees for achieving these
results doing it a plaquer I don't know
we get a heartfelt thank you
job well done thank you we have no
incentive compensation okay
representative Schmidt you had a
question
are we still using GRS as our actuars
thank you yes we are still using GRS and
they've done an excellent job
and continue to do that
okay
representative a bear
thank you madam chair
I I just had a couple of questions
is is there a reason why this
retirement
why there's an independent investment
committee it says it's appointed by who
this
if you could please turn to page 36 I'm
there I see it it says it's appointed by
it says it's quoting an RSA law but who
appoints this investment committee okay
um two of the members come directly from
the board which
um
in slide 35 the Board of Trustees right
exactly and so there are the two members
that are from the board
and then which the governor as well as
the executive council is is part of the
decision making there the governor would
appoint people and then the executive
Council would agree with them some of
them are appointed directly by the
governor to the board and some of them
are
suggest nominated by the the employees
themselves and some by the employers
so those are the those are two of the
people that are on the independent
investment committee and then there are
three people which as Marty discussed
earlier
um are required to be have extensive
professional experience and finance and
Investments the re reason I was not here
in 2009 when the legislature made this
decision but my understanding and Marty
referred to it earlier was that there
was a desire to have
stronger knowledge of Investments for
the group that makes the investment
decisions for nhrs
and so my follow-on question Madam chair
with you that was why is this not
privatized why are we depending on
people who are nominated and appointed
is that not a question representative a
bearer is a policy decision that we the
legislature have made thank you and we
can can obviously reconsider it at any
time
yes I alluded to earlier our performance
through June 30 2022 was better than 80
percent of our peers over a 10-year
period that put us in the top 18th
percentile and for the 13 years that
ended June 30 2022 that's the time for
which the iic has been making the
investment decisions the fund
outperformed 81 percent of our peers
and this app performance relative to the
other public pension plans
the median of their performance for that
13-year period added approximately 325
million dollars in additional returns to
our fund which is not an insignificant
amount
the next slide is on page 22.
and this Compares our assumed rate of
return with the national average of
other public pension plans
so you can see looking over at the far
left hand side of the slide nhrs
has consistently had a lower assumed
rate of return than many other pension
plans
and what determines the assumed rate of
return is the plan's actual Investments
the actuaries go through a very
complicated process of recommending an
assumed rate of return what they do is
they look at how what percent of our
portfolio is in domestic equities what
percent is in
foreign equities what percent is in
fixed income what percent is in real
estate and what percent is in different
alternative Investments and then they
pull a number of investment Consultants
to ask them what do you think these
different asset classes are going to
earn over the next five to ten years
and so the actuaries look at all of that
input and then apply that to the actual
weightings an hour
Investment Portfolio
and they come up with a number that they
think is reasonable based on that
and then our and then our board has this
and then our the iic signs off on that
and then the board votes on that so two
different pension plans may have very
different assumed rates of returns and
that doesn't mean that one is right and
the other one is wrong it just often
means that they have different Assets in
their portfolio and some states
Minneapolis com Minnesota comes to mind
it's a set in statute which is not a
good place to be and I think that used
so you can see that
it's it's a it's a difficult balance
coming up with something that is
realistic but is conservative and is
achievable and the board works hard to
get that balance right
and at this point I will turn things
over to Marty to talk more about
thank you Jan um we've we've kept here
for a while I hope it's been interesting
um and we will try to get you out of
here in time for lunch
um so you can get back for the the
dental stuff in the afternoon
um contributions and funding and this is
this is the slides I uh referred to when
representative leckis asked about some
of the history of the unfunded liability
so we're just going to start out member
contributions are set in statured as we
had previously mentioned and those are
the contribution rates for each of the
four member groups on Slide 23. the
police and fire pay and more that's
again a part of partially recognition of
the Social Security non not contributing
to that plan uh employer contributions
aren't set in statute those are
determined by the actuary and then
certified by the Board of Trustees every
two years our process not surprisingly
since we're created by Statute has our
rates set no later than October 1st
so that we can get numbers to the state
when they're doing their next two-year
budget you know we have moved that up to
help employers and we certified the
rates this this past summer in July
local employers pay 100 of those
contributions as we talked about earlier
and we also referenced the the one-time
payment last for last year's
contribution so
um slide 24 talks about oh yeah on that
point right now the employees pay the
bulk of their own retirement for the
active employees
the there is in statute of formula that
once the unfunded liability becomes
more manageable the employee rate will
go down until the employer and the
employee are paying equally toward their
uh tour of the retirement which is the
goal uh I don't it won't be happening
this year I'm afraid but that is the
plan yeah
Senator Schmidt
thank you madam chair so you were saying
a few moments ago that something is was
uh not in statute and that's a good
thing for new people they may not
realize that anything that's in statute
is not that easy to change because you
have to get the legislature on board
that's all time consuming and the
governor and so forth so it's a terrible
situation in some respects to have
something in statute
here
we're talking about the rates being set
in statute is that really working as
well as as an alternative method is that
what other states do as well they set
that in statute or are we an outlier
there on the member contribution side
Most states do set that in statute and
that you know that's sort of a give
gives the members a certainty uh you
know for what when they when they accept
positions what they're going to be
paying in that that's not uncommon on
the members member contributions to be
set in statute okay
and not everything is bad that's in
statute those were those were last
changed in 2011 in the house bill too
that I referred to earlier so you know
how does the actuary crunch the numbers
to come up with the rates
um this on slide 24. what they do is
it's called an Actuarial valuation and
they do one of those every two years for
us so it looks you know on on cycle so
it would there'll be evaluation for FY
2223 that we'll be seeing
um
no for 23 24 that we'll be seeing uh
then
um and they calculate the funding status
of the plan and set the employer rates
and those rates consist of three pieces
the normal cost and we'll talk about
each of these in detail on the next
Slide the unfunded liability or ual and
the medical subsidy rate each member
group has a separate rate based on the
demographics of that plan and there's a
number of assumptions that the actuary
uses in deriving these rates how long
are people going to live how old are
they going to be when they choose to
retire how many people I can invest and
you know walk away and not earn a
benefit from us how much are we going to
make in the markets are there all kinds
of assumptions that are based on a lot
of complex statistical models but they
are assumptions they're not facts so
every four years they do what's called
an Actuarial experience study where they
do two things they look back at the last
four years of experience and you know
other retirement rates
similar to what they they what they
expected them to be or the more where
the brutality rates moving things like
that and they also look forward it
Trends you know sort of nationally and
globally uh you know about things like
mortality and investment so so basically
there there's sort of constantly
resetting the assumptions as needed
because you can't get you
nothing nothing is going to turn out
exactly has anyone planned for anything
so there's a lot of moving Parts
involved in this so you want them to
sort of average out to where you want to
be
um type of thing so they're always
reviewing uh those and part of that is
the demographic so then the the other
piece is the economics which Jan spoke
to which is primarily the assumed rate
of return but also the wage inflation
rate is part of that as well as a is an
important piece
so we'll be getting another
um fiscal 23 will be the the end of the
last the next four year period will be
the board will be getting an experience
um so the the pieces of the employer
rate the the normal of the rate the
total rate is the normal cost and this
is the estimated annual cost of pension
benefits as they're earned this is how
the actuary basically projects out
everybody's individual
benefit scenarios based on on the um the
assumptions in place and then averages
them back together to get a normal cost
how much as a percentage of pain needs
to be set aside in a given year to fund
that person's benefit you know down the
road all of the member contributions go
towards the normal cost so to that
extent they're pre-funding their benefit
um by 65 to 70 percent of what their of
their ultimate benefit
um I'm going to jump to the bottom of
the slide for the medical subsidy
because it's a little bit shorter
um you know that's a pay-as-you-go rate
basically there's a finite pool that
tends to decline every year of people
receiving the medical subsidy this was
closed for teachers in 2009 for
employees back in the early 2000s
um anybody in group two had to be
working on June 30th of 2000 to qualify
so it's a finite pool for this insurance
premium offset and it's they fund it as
a pay as you go the actual real
calculate how many people are getting it
how much is the subsidy and how much do
we need for two years to keep it solvent
so there's no future projections on that
and the subsidy amounts are set in
statute they've been flat since 2008 and
um
there's a lower subsidy for people who
are Medicare eligible post 65 and that's
where most of the subsidy recipients are
now so it'll eventually go away as a
component of the rate but not for
several decades and then the middle the
unfunded liability this is this is sort
of the you know the big the origin story
for the retirement system so much is
packed into this this is the estimated
value of accrued nhrs benefits not yet
funded so this is future benefits
projected to be paid out to members
retirees and active members uh that we
don't have the funding in the trust fund
right now for uh it was 5.69 billion at
the close of the last fiscal year and
that's a funded ratio of 65.6 so we have
a little bit less than two-thirds
of all of the funds needed to meet our
future obligations and you know the
first thing you may jump to is well that
what happens if everybody wants their
money but it we pay out monthly benefits
over people's lifetimes so it's not like
people can go to the building and Loan
and ask for all their money back when
there's Iran on the bank you know we're
paying these out in orderly trashes over
decades so we have that time to rebuild
our funding and get get to where we want
to be on a funded level
um so so it's not you know um so
you know some states you know
liabilities aren't uncommon there are
some states that are fully funded 100
there are some that are in the 30s and
40s for funding a lot of those are more
policy decisions in those States than
economic decisions but in nhrs's case if
we have a constitutional amendment that
employees employers pay the full rate
and other other protections how come we
have this unfunded liability
and there are three main factors that
went into growing this liability uh in
the first and most dramatic was um the
sort of charging of artificially low
employer contributions from 1991 uh
through 2000 um and nine and what that
was was back in the early 90s there was
a a recession New Hampshire was
particularly hardly hit with real estate
a lot of the banks folded
um you know it was you know a lot of
people were losing jobs and they were
the retirement system rates were going
up uh in that 92 91 92 period because
the benefit increases that the
legislature granted in 88.89 so there
was pressure
um from local employers from the
governor's office you know what can be
done and the nhrs asked the actuary at
the time a firm called Buck you know
what was the best way to actually fund
the plan and they did a lengthy report
you know in the executive summer very
the first page recommended to close
30-year amortization using the entry age
normal method uh you know and then the
second page of the summary said but
there's three other ways you can do it
too that are acceptable under current
practice and you give a sort of a menu
to a decision maker in a tight budget
time they're going to pick the cheapest
option and that's what happened the
legislature uh passed the bill back in
91 that changed the funding the way we
calculate the funding of the retirement
system to something called a open group
aggregate which is no longer an accepted
method they also mandated that the board
set the assume rate of return for the
next year at 9.75
um you know which again the higher the
rate the lower the employer
contributions and this was a temper
build as a temporary solution to a
short-term crisis you know economic
issues in New Hampshire and that they
did give the board back uh the setting
of The assumed rate of return a year
later and they we've never should have
taken it away from fiduciary perspective
but this funding methodology stayed on
the books until it was repealed in 2007.
so what you have is you know you drilled
a hole in the bottom of your boat you
forgot about it for 15 years and then
your ankle started getting damp
eventually and you realize there was a
hole there so that was that was one of
the reasons why the liability was
growing and the way the funding was
calculated didn't really show up in the
reports on top of that there was
something that started in the 80s
called gain sharing and this was a a
representative Gerhart had a question
about performance over and above the
assumed rate of return and
um back in the 80s and 90s the
legislature set a ceiling where if we
exceeded our assumed rate of return in a
given year by a certain amount usually
about
um a half a percentage Point any funds
any investment income over that over and
above the assumed rate of return was
segregated to pay for other benefits so
that was primarily colas and the medical
subsidy and if you consistently exceed
your assume rate of return it's great
because you've got money you flush with
money but if you have a year where you
have a down year and you don't have that
assume rate of return you also don't
have that cushion anymore because the
funds are dedicated to something else so
so that was sort of a structural issue
with what was called the special account
and that with the great the.com bubble
in o102 we had negative investment years
there
um in the legislature and and some of
the member and employer groups got
together and they recognized there was
some issues structurally with the way
that the plan was funded and you know
that took about four or five years of
Genesis and discussions to get a bill
passed in 27 2007 that went back to
close 30-year amortization entry age
normal
um for the funding and made some other
structural changes that fix those leaks
um you know in the basement but you know
2007 what happened almost
contemporaneously with those changes the
Great Recession that you know
um so that really exacerbated you know
we had this whole you know it was two
two billion plus and then the markets
collapsed you know and we lost a billion
that year and that just made the
unfunded all that much more challenging
so so that's kind of how we got here and
we've been digging out of that for the
past 13 years and making slow but steady
progress
uh let's see so um next slide slide 26
this just shows the employer
contribution rates for fiscal 24 25
which is uh taking effect this July 1st
uh the gray column in the middle shows
the unfunded liability as a portion of
the total pension cost so employers
77 to 85 percent of what they're paying
in HRS are for these
decisions made in the past that you know
we're paying for now
um without the unfunded liability and it
you can't wipe it away you know it is
already Adept that it's accrued
um the normal cost of the pension you
know for employees it's under 10 the
employ the members are paying seven
percent of that themselves so the the
normal cost for for the employer are is
relatively low and once the liability
generally gets reduced to a more
manageable level
um you know the total employer rates are
going to stabilize as well lower and as
representative McGuire
um reference there is some statutory
language to when they Bounce Down they
can't go below the member rate and when
they get to that level they'll both go
up and down together uh after that so
but that's again probably talking 2040s
at best on that uh and the the footnote
on slide 26 just shows the member share
of the employer cost so that's what
their contributions represent uh as to
how much their pre-framed their own
benefit
the next slide 27 just shows that the
current FY 2223 rates versus 2425
they're all going down this is the first
time all four rates have gone down uh in
anyone's memory we had a little bit of a
dip with employees and and the group two
rates back in 2018 but that this is
larger this is because of the five-year
investment performance through June 30th
of 21 was strong enough to to lower
these rates a little
um you know the expectation is that the
rates aren't going to go down
dramatically over the next 15 years
they're going to hopefully stay around
this level you know with a little bit of
variation so let's get give employers
more certainty
um you know and that's in 2039 is when
five of the 5.7 billion unfunded
liability is scheduled to be paid down
so
um so that's where we're looking at is
yes I I just
um
in response to the question about the
invest uh independent investment
committee uh am I remembering correctly
that that was recommended by the
2007 decennial Commission
yes and and just for information of new
members that group that meets every 10
years does a very deep dive into all
aspects of the system and looks at
things such as the effectiveness of the
investment committee and so forth thank
you
thank you representative yeah but both
uh the 2007 and 17 commission led to a
number of legislative and enactments
they weren't the exact rep
recommendations of the committee in
every sense but you know they were along
the general theme and
um you know they were pretty pretty
positive improvements uh generally
speaking
um
see
um Egypt just as a follow-up reference
to the investment committee all of the
folks that we have now on the investment
are volunteers in our compensated
um for that other than for mileage uh
you know in lunch when they meet so
um we're um you know and they're all in
wealth management or Investments are
retired from those fields
um so I only have a couple slides left
and then Jane only has a few as well but
legislation obviously what we're here
for
um last year uh well the last three
years 2021 there were 11 bills
introduced related to nhrs in some way
and one uh was enacted uh last year they
were 13 and seven were enacted including
one that was retained from 2021 uh this
year last day I checked this morning
there were 20 lsrs listed relating to
nhrs so that's when I say you're going
to be sick of me in two or three weeks
um you will because it'll be here quite
a bit uh testifying or answering
questions on those bills since 2007 that
that magical year again we've tracked
more than 100 changes to the statute
since 2007 some extremely significant
member contributions employer
contributions benefits and some more
um cleanup or clarification things like
that but you know cumulatively you know
that those who keep us hopping typically
a lot of these are
represent the need to reprogram our
systems change some of our materials
things like that so so we we work hard
to to get all that information out there
and
as a as a component unit of state
government you know
um nhrs isn't here to lie before or
against any outcomes we feel that as you
know as the plan sponsor the legislature
makes policy decisions and we really
just want to get the relevant facts in
front of you so you have information to
make sound reasonable decisions
um you know the only time nhrs would
take a position on a bill is if there's
a concern that it violates the Internal
Revenue code or would be challenged our
fiduciary duty to act in solely in the
best interests of the members and
beneficiaries
um as I mentioned last year briefly
there was a bill about China divestment
and the board actually opposed that on
fiduciary grounds not so much on the
merits or or certainly not on the merits
of the Chinese government and the way
they treat their people but on the
provision that you know we want to
de-politicize or you know our investment
decisions or keep them apolitical and
just looking at you know what are the
best investments for our
um our membership in the universe of
allowable you know investment
performance because you know if you
start
um sort of adding mandates on investing
or divesting in different places you
know legislatures change from session to
session and you could be
all of your um you know your long-term
Investments could get get kind of tossed
in a hopper so there's been sort of a
steady those one of the few things that
the boards have tended to consistently
oppose there was a bill a few years back
to stretch out paying off the liability
longer that exposes us more with the
board of pose that but generally I'm
going to try to be you know Switzerland
you know Joe Friday here when I'm
testifying
um so that that's how we work we do have
handouts on more of the complicated
bills that we try to provide to the
committee to supplement the fiscal note
with a little bit of history and
background those we call those Bill
briefs so you'll see those from me as
well and that's that's um yeah well one
thing you'll notice is that we made some
bad decisions in 1991 that we're still
paying for because
we didn't go back and look at them so
that's one very good reason to Deep dive
every now and then and if we did go to
that Actuarial method I'm sure the board
would be opposing it yeah there's a lot
of if we knew now if we knew then what
we knew now
um
and I'll turn it back over to Gian shoes
it has a couple of summary slides to tie
it all up and and then we'll stay as
long as you want for questions
thank you very much Marty and I've been
able to get the answer to the question
on the Chinese Investments at this point
um it we have a total of 47 million
dollars in market value and that
represents
2.57 percent of our non-us Equity
Holdings which are 1.8 billion dollars
so it's a very small fraction of our
overall portfolio yes representative
Fitzpatrick I'd just like to clarify
that my question about investing in
China
wasn't about politics it's just
I I think that the current climate that
we're in makes it a very risky
investment
so
well thank you for that concern and
I'm very glad in that case that it's a
thank you madam chair um continue on
page 30. and asmari said I'll try to do
a very brief summary
um as we've tried to show you today that
we do provide a very modest pension
benefit and the majority of those
benefits that we pay stay in state and
support our local economies we have a
plan in place thanks to the legislature
to pay down our unfunded liability so
we're eating the spinach as are our
employers and it's it's working
um the board has taken responsible steps
to assure that the proper plan funding
um by having a reasonable rate of return
and continue to improve our funded ratio
page 31 this shows how our funded ratio
compares to our peers we
we have not yet received sufficient
information to have this updated for FY
22 but as you can see that we have been
closely tracking although we have been
below that of our peers but we are
definitely trending in the right
direction you can see that on page 31
and then page 32
um this to me is an incredibly
fascinating slide because Maine our
neighbor to the North and the East they
were at the same place we were 10 years
prior to when we started to deal with
our unfunded liability and they have
made enormous strides while having very
similar demographics that we do similar
number of active and retirees very
similar average pension
have similar constitutional requirements
and also having a plan to fully pay off
the unfunded liability
so you can see that there FY 22 funded
ratio was just under 84 percent so I'm
hoping in 10 years we're going to look a
lot like this if not better
page 33
nhrs is a constitutional and statutory
Foundation to protect its financial
future we just need to keep staying on
the path and going in the right
direction
we are fortunate that our state has a
constitutional
language that requires that the
contribution rates be paid be paid by
the employers and be actuarially sound
most other states do not have this we're
very fortunate here in New Hampshire
and that our we periodically make
changes to our retirement statutes as
passed and enacted by the legislature
and the because we've those changes have
been made we're able to address the
structural issues that Marty talked
about earlier
and just like any other serious Endeavor
in life this is not going to be fixed in
a week or a month this is truly a
marathon but we have the stamina and the
capacity to get us to 100 funding and so
we thank you for your support in helping
us get there
and I apologize if we've gone over our
allotted time but we appreciate all the
questions and would be happy to answer
any others well thank you the the
questions are are important because we
need to understand the system yes
representative leckis thank you um so
some of the slides are basically
illegible due to the size I was
wondering if you could send us like an
electronic maybe a PDF or something
format so if we want to zoom in on
individual items thank you
yes
okay
all right I think we will close the
formal part of the meeting if you have
immediate questions I'm sure they'll be
able to answer them we'll resume at one
o'clock on the performance audit of the
Dental Board
and thank you all
foreign
I think nearly everybody's back from
exactly representative Schmidt you're
I saw him walking out of the cafeteria
so yes
okay
well good afternoon Madam chair members
of the committee for the record I'm
Steve Smith I'm the director of audits
for the office of legislative budget
assistant
and with me is uh Steve Grady he was the
senior in charge manager on the
Dental examination report that he and he
will present that but for the benefit of
the committee just very quickly I'm just
going to go over a quick overview of
what a performance audit is and how we
go about conducting a performance audit
um
how many people don't have
do you have them we also brought some
full box in the in the committee office
and some people uh browse through them
[Music]
thank you for for waiting
thank you
okay
so when we talk about performance audits
as the name
indicates we're assessing the
performance of a department or an agency
or program it differs from a financial
audit which our office also does where
we are auditing a set of financial
statements or a set a set of financial
transactions or the controls around
Financial transactions
so this focuses on a performance audit
which is the report before you so
performance audits we you know things
that we consider the extent to which
expected results established by you the
legislature were achieved the
effectiveness of agencies or programs or
functions
and whether the The Entity under audit
complied with laws and regulations
um
typically we
if I could sum it up the Effectiveness
and efficiency of what the Oddity is
doing and are they doing what they're
supposed to be doing or could they be
doing it better
um the topics are provided to us by The
Joint legislative
um
Performance Auto oversight committee
lpaoc
so they give us the topics and we put
them in our queue and as as uh staff and
jobs cycle we We Begin an audit
um usually an audit begins with an
entrance meeting with the with the
agency where we talk about the as we
proceed the scope to be of the audit
um
logistical information and usually an
initial request of information that we
to allow us to begin to
as you can imagine depending upon the
topic there's a lot of Education that we
have to go through we're not experts in
everything
so depending upon what the department or
or the The Entity under audit is we have
to learn about what they do what the
laws are around them things of that
nature
and once once we do that we prepare
what's called a scope statement which
kind of outlines what we're going to
look at kind of assemble a question you
know how efficient how effective did
ex-agency do this
and then
um looking to kind of the methodology as
to how we're going to go about doing
that and we go back before the lpoc
committee to make sure that what we
intend to do is what they had envisioned
so they approved that scope statement
and then we take it from there and that
allows us to develop an audit plan which
is an internal document to us which sets
out the audit objectives we refine the
methodologies and assess risks things of
that nature
um so that's our planning document of
how and what we plan to do on the topic
and then we begin our our work our field
work as we call it which can involve
several interviews surveys
examination of of information files
documents things that the that the
Oddity has to allow us to assess what
they're doing
and um and then based on the evidence
and based on what we learn we if if we
discover things that aren't happening
the way they should or things are
happening that shouldn't be happening
out of compliance or or areas of
improvement best practice things of that
nature we develop what's called
observations some people call them
findings we prefer to call them
observations
and so there's a criteria that we follow
to develop those
and they all get put into a report along
with background information to allow the
reader to know about the the Oddity
under audit
and then we would draft that report we
would give it to the Oddity and we
request responses to our observations
and responses to our recommendations
that we're making
and that
can go from anywhere from three weeks to
several months depending upon the the
agency under under audit
um and then once we get those responses
back we assess them make sure that
they uh
depending upon the level of concurrence
if they totally disagree or they don't
concur the observation we try to
work with them to bring some level of
concurrence there because sometimes
they're just reading it wrong whatever
and then once once we're comfortable
with that we have what's called an exit
meeting which is the final go through of
the report
and then the report is goes into
production goes through our QC process
and then eventually gets presented at
the fiscal committee
and that's what we did with this report
back in November and um
after we presented the fiscal committees
the report gets distributed to a variety
of different people the chair gets one
of Edna for example and after that
if we could call back to like for
example today to a committee to present
it we're more than happy to do that so
that's a very quick overview of the
process hopefully that was
um but but certainly as topics you
become aware or have concerns our
preferences as you go through the lpoc
contact a member they have senators and
representatives there and occasionally
we get an audit that shows up in
legislation for example the freedom
accounts is on our to-do list but that
won't happen until the fall because it's
a fairly new
new program
but our preference is is not to have it
in legislation because if it's in
legislation now we're Bound by timelines
and things of that nature and we don't
the nature of what we do we don't like
to be bound by a timeline or a deadline
because once we begin an audit you never
know where it's going to lead you and we
want to be able to be as thorough and as
as informative as we can be
to to you folks our audience so any
questions on that before I turn it over
thank you for the record I am Steve
Grady I am a senior performance audit
manager for the audit division I was the
InCharge auditor for the Dental Board
performance audit the audit assessed how
efficiently and effectively the board
administered the regulation of dentistry
and dental hygiene during State fiscal
years 2019 and 2020.
we also examined matters outside that
period as well as office of professional
licensure and certification controls or
oplc when they directly affected board
operations management controls are
processes that provide reasonable
assurances that an agency achieves its
objectives
objectives fall into three broad
categories
the efficiency and effectiveness of
operations
reliability of information used for
reporting
in compliance with laws rules and other
requirements while not exceeding
delegated authority
our executive summary begins on page one
there we conclude the board lacked
adequate controls to ensure a
consistently achieved expected outcomes
and that it complied with requirements
while doing so
the board was expected to protect the
public health safety and Welfare from
unqualified unscrupulous or impaired
dentists and hygienists through three
primary functions credentialing
monitoring and enforcement
however the board did not monitor its
own Effectiveness it could not
demonstrate its requirements helped
achieve expected outcomes its regulatory
program was largely subjective
credentials were issued that did not
meet statutory and other requirements
credential holder qualification was
ineffectively controlled and monitored
Enforcement cases were inconsistently
managed and resolved
the board lacked controls over its own
compliance it engaged in extra legal and
extra jurisdictional acts such as
improperly delegating is discretionary
Authority in creating its own
credentials
the board in Effectiveness was
underpinned in part by inconsistent
support from other agencies notably the
oplc
leadership and staff turnover inadequate
management controls and an inadequately
structured relationship between the two
agencies limited effectiveness
furthermore there was no accountability
framework to ensure the quality of oplc
provided Services was acceptable to the
board and that substandard Service
delivery delivery was remedied
records are poorly managed and controls
were poorly understood
many board actions were unauditable
consequently we were compelled to
qualify our use of and our conclusions
resting on board records and at the
stations
our recommendation summary follows on
page five
of the 36 observations 33 have board
recommendations the board concurred with
22 and concurred in part with 11.
10 observations have oplc
recommendations and management concurred
with all of them
20 observations have legislative
suggestions or recommendations that may
require the responsible agency to seek
legislative action
I will next summarize the report's five
chapters
chapter one starts on page 11.
IT addresses systemic management control
deficiencies
well-designed controls can help agencies
efficiently and effectively achieve
outcomes comply with requirements and
protect public resources however
controls were often absent or
ineffectively designed inconsistently
implemented unmonitored and unrefined
there were no strategies plans or
performance goals objectives or targets
risk management practices were informal
qualitative and intuition based
prominent uncontrolled risks included
regulatory capture and federal antitrust
scrutiny
regulatory capture occurs when the board
misuses its delegated authority and
discretion to pursue private or industry
interests over the public interest
Federal antitrust laws were intended to
protect competition for Consumer benefit
while the legislature could act in its
Sovereign capacity and limit competition
to achieve public objectives the board
could not
legislative suggestions include
overseeing the board's audit remediation
efforts and structuring controls of
regulatory agencies to ensure they
follow State policy and receive active
State supervision
board recommendations include developing
apps and controls and improving existing
controls
board compliance was a basic expectation
but at times it waived failed to fully
implement or actively circumvented State
policy
it inconsistently complied with the
right to no law the administrative
procedure act and ethics laws among
others
it took extra legal and extra
jurisdictional actions extra legal Acts
were board actions taken outside the
authority delegated to any agency
truncating the separation of powers
extra jurisdictional Acts were board
actions taken that were under another
agency's Authority
in some areas the board effectively set
State policy instead of the general
court
the board knowingly and unknowingly
engaged in ad hoc rulemaking
an ad hoc rule was a requirement imposed
on someone outside the board but which
was not properly adopted and was
consequently not legally enforceable
knowingly enforcing ad hoc rules was
abusive
or non-compliance also added to
regulatory complexity compromised
transparency and left timeliness
unmeasured
board recommendations include complying
with laws and rules and discontinuing
extra legal and extra jurisdictional
actions
the board's organization was inadequate
it lacked an adequate number of public
members
subordinated entities had no public
the board's only statutory subordinate
entity had outlived its purpose and
acted outside its statutory scope
the board fabricated subordinate
entities and improperly delegated
substantive duties to them including
regulating segments of the dental care
industry
these extra legal entities were not
actively controlled by the board
they operated outside of State control
and legislative and public oversight
they inconsistently complied with
transparency ethics and other
requirements
legislative suggestions include
increasing the number of public board
members while holding steady or
decreasing the number of prudentialed
members
and ensuring authorized subordinate
entities have an adequate number of
public members
board recommendations include
discontinuing the operation of extra
legal subordinate entities and actively
controlling authorized subordinate
entities
the board routinely but improperly
delegated its Collective discretionary
decision-making Authority
consequently yes ma'am excuse me when do
you want questions at any time okay I
believe we have one at least sorry
no worries um can you give me an example
of one of their subordinate entities uh
what they do specifically they created
what they called the Anastasia
anesthesia and sedation evaluation
committee and that committee was
responsible for a number of things to
include from developing Draft rules to
propose to the board to regulate
dentists anesthesia and sedation permits
as well as the members conducting
inspections and evaluation of applicants
and
consequently substantively regulating
their behavior
so ASAC isn't something that we approved
that's correct okay thank you so they
yes
and by rules in that context are these
rules that were properly created through
541a or did they just create their own
rules and Implement them on their own
without that
they so there are a number of
subordinated entities the asec itself
was created via RSA 541a adopted rule a
long time ago uh they also created
without any rules uh an advisory
subcommittee of that body so the board
had engaged in creating these extra
legal entities in a couple of different
ways
um did they
and either the board itself or some of
these entities created they actually put
in place and enforce rules that were not
did not go through the proper rulemaking
process that's correct yes thank you
represent Gerhard uh Madam chairman
is the usual term sure
um can you tell us what page you're
going to only because I see you you're
going through I have this black box with
your face is no it's fine I'm just if
you're just saying it was you know just
I don't know just I can follow along
better instead of just having it listen
thank you
okay represent goalie
thank you madam chair quick question
does what happens
or is there any recourse when these
boards do this and go outside their
scope of what they're there to do
or is it something we should be looking
into going further down the road it's
something we should be looking into
um I'd also while we're talking about it
I'd like to mention that performance
audits are not always well followed up
and this one in particular
I know that we are revising the statutes
controlling the Dental Board and their
relationship with the oplc so I wouldn't
be worried about some of the issues
creating subordinate entities is not a
statutory problem but
I don't expect us to take major action
because we have statutory changes in
process
but I think we should be aware of what's
going on and what the board and the oplc
are doing about it
they may yeah I I mean I'm just going by
listening to and it's troubling
listening some of these ethics stuff
that we're in here and there's some
examples and a lot of other things in
there that are very troubling to hear
from that is going on in a board uh yes
I agree
um I think we will ask
so PLC what we can do about board
members who will are in that situation I
thank you another quick representative
Schmidt
thank you madam chair
so do we have anybody from the boat here
today
board has been invited and they are
expected to show up approximately 2 p.m
so uh
and a lot of the stuff you're talking
about is outside the scope of practice
yes when we draw conclusions about
something being extra legal or extra
jurisdictional and it is outside what
has clearly been delineated in statute
as something that the Dental Board in
this case should be engaging in and did
you compare the things that they were
doing aside from the fact whether what
they're doing is legal or not I'm
suspending any judgment about that but
but is what they were doing is this in
line with what's Dental practices doings
Nationwide or in in New England or
something like that this is whole cloth
on their part
um but it is it consistent with
um any Dental trends that you're aware
of that you could compare
some of the things that we observed for
example some of the credentials that
lack statutory basis in New Hampshire
law are something that other states will
allow for in statute for their board to
regulate so it's not beyond the realm of
plausibility
however the concerns that we number one
arrive at are that they'd lack statutory
authority to do it in many cases for
example creating a credential on their
own the board is actually prohibited
from doing that in RSA 541a uh and other
things as well as creating you know
their own subordinate entities out of
out of thin air if you will um is also a
Prohibition that they're they're not
allowed to do so
um that some of the things are plausibly
useful uh we don't question that but
they certainly did not follow proper
procedures nor did they typically
objectively establish that those
credentials or those entities were
needed in order for them to successfully
regulate dentistry in the state a
follow-up question follow up so and
during this time frame speaking as a
member of the gel car for the last 16
years and representative McGuire the
chair has been on the jail car for eight
or ten of those years so so did they did
the boat appear before the jail card
during this time frame at all and
present any of these
so changes right so the last major
update to the board's rules were in 2017
there were some updates in 2018 and 2020
they do not directly affect the things
that we're discussing and expressing
concerns with respect to being extra
legal or extra jurisdiction although
thank you
okay thank you very much absolutely
picking up on page 57 the board
routinely but improperly delegated his
Collective discretionary decision-making
Authority consequently over 97 percent
of initial licenses were issued either
before or without board action
99.9 percent of credentials were renewed
without board action some complaints
were acted upon without board control
and some investigations were conducted
and some cases closes without a record
of board Direction
also the board lacked a performance
management system to help evaluate its
performance or objectively demonstrate
it achieved expected outcomes
our recommendations here include the
board and oplc detailing their
relationship in rules
if they cannot or will not do so timely
we suggest the legislature consider
either requiring adoption of integrated
Rules by a specific date or detailing
their interrelationship in statute
I I will I will mention there was a
study committee on the relationship of
oplc to boards in general and there is a
major rewrite of the statutory
connection between boards and oplc that
we will be considering later this term
so
we that issue is understood and maybe
not solved but didn't work
very good
other board recommendations include
discontinuing the delegation of
discretionary Authority discontinuing
the delegation of other authority
without effective controls ensuring
delegated tasks are properly
accomplished and improving performance
the oplc beginning on page 75 describes
oplc control's adversely affecting board
operations
the oplc's organization and controls
have been in flux since its Creation in
2015.
no cohesive control framework existed to
ensure duties delegated to the oplc were
only administrative in nature oplc
provided Services met assigned agencies
needs and the oplc was accountable for
performance
no Performance Management System existed
to demonstrate the oplc achieved
expected outcomes
cost accounting was inadequate and the
actual costs of services provided to
assigned agencies could not be
established
fee setting and administration were
inadequate
leading to unrecovered costs
unauthorized and gratuitous fees being
charged and non-compliance with the
requirement the board collect 125
percent of its direct costs
unresolved untimely resolved and
temporarily resolved control defects
identified in Prior audits contributed
to ongoing and in some cases worsening
deficiencies
many control defects we identified may
also affect the other 50 odd agencies
legislative suggestions include
clarifying oplc roles and
responsibilities structuring interagency
accountability and either continuing to
regulate occupations using bodies like
the board or migrating regulatory
authority to administrative agency like
the oplc
oplc recommendations include developing
a well-designed system of controls to
optimize performance ensuring it
complies with requirements stabilizing
its organization
implementing an effective cost
accounting system
improving customer service and
accountability
and ensuring audit findings are timely
and durably remediated
board recommendations include improving
chapter 2 starting on page 117 addresses
the regulatory program encompassed the
board's three functions however it
lacked a structured evidence and
risk-based approach to rationalizing
implementing and administering State
policy and structuring its regulatory
program
consequently its regulatory program was
largely subjective and contained
inconsistencies
there were several potential barriers to
entry and credential portability was
inadequate
participation in certain occupations was
inappropriately Limited
licensees of other boards were
improperly regulated
aspects of dental practice were not
regulated as required by Statute
controls are often Reliant upon ad hoc
rules and extra legal credentials
board recommendations include developing
a cohesive evidence and risk-based
Regulatory strategy
objectively identifying threats to the
public and which threats can be cost
effectively regulated
in discontinuing regulations without
statutory Authority and perfunctory
chapter 3 begins on page 141.
credentialing was intended to ensure
individuals wishing wishing to practice
in the state were qualified however
controls were inadequate and practices
were inconsistent with requirements
before issuing a credential the board
was required to make a finding each
applicant was qualified and that there
were no circumstances that could be
grounds for discipline
however over 97 percent of initial
licenses were issued before or without a
board Act
some credentials were issued based upon
applications that did not comply with
requirements
dentist anesthesia and sedation permit
requirements inadequately protected the
public
hygienist anesthesia and sedation
permits lack statutory Authority as did
expanded function Dental auxiliary
permits when they were initially
established
neither these hygienist permits nor the
certified public health dental hygienist
credential were objectively demonstrated
to be necessary
the scope and scale of dental assistant
regulation was similar to licensure but
lacked underpinning statutory Authority
board recommendations include reviewing
and approving applications before
credentials are issued discontinuing the
expanded function Dental auxiliary
permit hygienist anesthesia and sedation
permits and the certified public health
dental hygienist certificate unless it
can demonstrate they if cost effectively
achieve outcomes
we also recommend they substantially
revise dental assistant regulation to
chapter 4 beginning on page 203
addresses monitoring
systematic compliance monitor yes
I'm sorry
representative true thank you thank you
madam chair
just to let you know this is my first
day on this committee
licensure
somebody from out of state or in-state
goes to the board and says I'm a dentist
so they have licensure is them
is somebody proving that like going back
to their college or whatever
proving all the steps that yes he's a
dentist that and that's what wasn't done
so yes credentialing is establishing
that the applicant has the underpinning
educational experience Etc
under their belt so that they are
reasonably qualified to engage in
dentistry or dental hygiene and it was
done but the board did not actually make
the findings that it was required to by
Statute so it was done perhaps it was
done by an individual member of the
board
but not the whole board it may have been
done by staff and referred over to the
board just for approval or in some cases
credentials were just issued without any
board involvement whatsoever
systematic compliance monitoring can
help ensure ongoing qualification to
practice however the board designed few
proactive controls to help prevent
adverse effects on the public
instead it primarily relied upon
reactive complaint-based controls that
inherently followed an adverse effect
board requirements that could have
helped proactively achieve outcomes were
ineffective and often perfunctory this
included credential renewals 99.9
percent of which occurred without a
board action
criminal history records checks which
were not conducted for any of the 430
initial licenses issued
continuing education requirements which
inconsistently ensured credential holder
competency
yeah
representative
thank you um I'm not sure what you're
reading I'm I can kind of follow where
you are but is this something that's
actually in here you're reading or do
you have written testimony you could
send to the committee
I can provide the script that I'm
reading from right I am not please yes
continue on
verification of compliance with other
requirements typically rested solely
upon credential holder attestations
complaints were inconsistently resolved
and record keeping was so poor that we
could not reliably establish the board
addressed all 109 complaints that it
received
board recommendations included improving
compliance monitoring subjecting
applicants to criminal history records
checks independently verifying
compliance with requirements instead of
relying on attestations
either discontinuing credential renewals
or making renewals and effective public
protection control and improving
controls over complaints
foreign
251.
chapter 5 addresses enforcement
four records prevented us from
quantifying the total number of
Investigations or adjudicatory
proceedings and hearings
thank you madam chair
my question as I go through this is
if you were to do a word check in here
in the report do you have any idea do I
have any idea I do not have any idea on
how many times an adequate appears in
this report or words like it and then
um follow on follow-up follow-up
question
um
when I was reviewing the report and the
the response to the audit
I was
coming from in Aerospace and defense
background when we go through any kind
of audit you claim responsibility and
you you take it and you fix it as I was
reading through here there was just no
no
um
responsibility taken really in
on uh page B1 which is
um
in the um in the
addendums at the back of it so appendix
B so I just wanted to make that comment
thank you
thank you any other question
some matters were not investigated but
nonetheless dismissed
some investigations were incomplete
adjudicatory proceedings and hearings
were inconsistently held or even pursued
disciplinary processes and sanctions
were inconsistent some sanctions were
informal or unpublished
compliance with sanctions was
inconsistently monitored
inadequate support contributed to many
deficiencies as the board was largely
relying upon other agencies to carry out
enforcement related activities
some matters were dismissed because of
insufficient support not because the
board had objectively established that
non-compliance did not occur
board recommendations include conducting
required investigations holding required
hearings monitoring case progress and
timeliness and monitoring compliance
with sanctions
oplc recommendations include revising
current board members and oplc
management did not create all the
defective controls we identified
many defects were long-standing
neither were many of the defects unique
to the board several prior audits
identified similar inadequacies in the
operations of other Regulatory Agencies
before and after the creation of the
oplc
nonetheless current members and
management were responsible for
efficiency and effectiveness it will
likely take several years to address
this audit's recommendations and develop
and Implement an effective regulatory
program objectively shown to efficiently
achieve expected results
integration of border and oplc controls
has reportedly begun
however whether how and when the board
will remediate other defects was
inconsistently clear
no relevant plans have been published
the board inconsistently recognized
limitations on its Authority it
disagreed with the need to follow some
fundamental State policy requirements
consequently we suggest the general
court consider how expanded oversight
could help ensure the board effectively
carries out State policy and complies
with the limitations imposed upon it
while doing so
I want to thank you for the taking the
time to allow us to speak here today if
there are any further questions I'd be
I don't have a question I just want to
thank you for an excellent report it was
concise it was clear thank you for
asking for the page numbers and
thank you more than welcome
yes I'm I'm sure that this is not going
to be solved instantaneously
any other questions for the auditors
all right thank you very much we
we have both the oplc and a member of
the dental board with us uh
I think
let's see what perhaps we'll hear from
the board first
good afternoon Madam chair and members
of the committee uh I'm Dr Punit kocher
I'm the president of the New Hampshire
Board of dental examiners and I'm joined
by my fellow board member Dr Howard
Ludington
so you already had the report we'll take
questions
I'm sure there will be questions I'm
just curious what your plan is
to address the I mean there's a large
number of issues what's your plan to
address the
these concerns
so we have already started uh We've
started working on the recommendations
regarding the anesthesia there is a bill
that has already been proposed so that's
I think in the yellow star stages
so that's there we have this as a
standing line item for every meeting
this this report was just accepted in
December so our first meeting was this
morning we've identified issues that the
board is already working on the hygiene
committee has already been transferred
the issues concerning the hygiene rules
so they're going to start looking on
that and then every month we're going to
start working through the
recommendations that have been brought
forth by the audit committee
go that sounds like a good start uh
representative Gerhard and the neighbor
uh thank you madam chair
quick question as to the necessity and
all of all this how many issues have
there been with dentists improperly
conducted like you know what I mean how
many times have as a dentist has really
been sanctioned to the point of
felony conviction or how serious is how
serious are the
concerns they're bringing forth so most
of the Committees most of the audit
committee's report works on is
identified you can say functional issues
so the way the board has been conducting
business in the past so like as board
members as the faces around the table
change everybody inherits the operating
environment of the board and that's
what's been inherited and we've now had
this opportunity from the audit
committee to report back to say hey okay
you're doing this but you got to justify
the action why you're doing this or
rules need to be made clearer so that
people are not interpreting rules
themselves that's what they're talking
about the ad hoc rules so that is what
we are working on as far as the dentist
being is disciplined it depends on Case
by case as the case comes up it goes
through now the enforcement division
which was not there before previously
doj used to run the investigation and
that was the time when we did not have
support doj would say we have too many
cases pending we just can't take this on
so they would want a board member to be
the investigator as well as be the judge
yeah
I think the the question was more a
matter of
how many substantiated complaints do you
get relative to the number of dentists
and hygienists in the state so I would
say on a monthly basis we would probably
get two to three complaints
so we meet once a month
and then those cases get complaint
doesn't mean that that's a warranted
complaint that that has any Merit to it
when the complaint comes to the board
the board will see fit to say okay
whether it needs to be investigated or
not and then if we're getting two to
three complaints a month maybe one is
being referred out for investigation to
enforcement where we say okay there is
Merit to that complaint
yeah one one of the things that I think
you're getting at is we our complaints
our job is Public Safety that's all we
think about a lot of the complaints we
get are insurance claims billing
components the public is confused about
our role in regards to Public Safety so
we deal with just Public Safety
complaints and there's not a lot of
those but they're dealt with very
quickly
okay thank you thank you any other
whoever some goalie oh somewhere a bear
and mangoli
thank you madam chair
um my question to the board is
following this audit what was your first
board meeting like did you guys get to
root cause what was the conversation
around this audit and
and why I mean there's a lot here a lot
of falling down
so we would have a monthly meeting with
Steve and his committee and so the board
would meet monthly it was not that all
the report came back as one and we met
only once so entire over the entire
period the audit was happening the board
was meeting every time some of the
observations were eye-opening
and some of them I think Steve and we
were on opposite ends we understand it
the reasoning behind so like you know
whether the observation could be what
Steve was saying okay you are not
controlling this committee and we would
say the way we are controlling a
committee is by having one board member
be part of the committee but those were
conversations we had
but in the end obviously as we learned
on how the operating environment was
functioning that okay certain certain
credentials are there where uh just to
name one we were talking about this this
morning certified public health Channel
hygienist okay that credential was
created the person gets that credential
that okay once that person has been
given that credential why is there not a
separate containing education
requirement for that credential
but because we are dentists in the field
we understand the person who can get
that credential is already a dental
hygienist who needs to sell to satisfy
CA requirements for being a dental
hygienist till the time the northern
dental hygienist they cannot become a
certified public health General agent so
those were the conversations we've had
but I think it comes down basically to
making sure that our rules are exactly
what the RSA States and making it simple
so that people can understand that hey
thank you madam chair thank you for
coming here
my question goes to I mean I heard some
of the issues you're addressing
currently
but I think one of the biggest issues I
heard was
folks being credentialed
without even being reviewed
or without a proper background check you
want to talk about Public Safety that's
where it starts is to making sure that
happens and I don't know if some of this
might be taken care of with now the
office of professional licensure being
able to review some of those where they
couldn't in the past it was
automatically licensed granted after so
many days if it hadn't been reviewed
but
what are you doing to make sure that
doesn't happen again because it was a
substantial number of credentials that
were authorized without even being
reviewed so I'll make a correction to
that not that it wasn't being reviewed
every applicant gets reviewed the
background check so the state the New
Hampshire Board of dental examiners are
actually approached the state
legislators to have a background check
for every new license he put forth even
though that RSA was passed the oplc or
the division prior to the oplc had not
set up the resources for a background
check to be done that has now been put
put forth so starting this year every
everybody who's applying for a new
credential goes through a background
check
so what do I understand you correctly to
say that the criminal background check
was a new requirement that was
implemented sometime after it was
imposed as a requirement
correct
thank you that's a little better
representative
thank you
um
so I I read through a chunk of this uh
in particular some of the ones where the
board concurred in part and kind of my
takeaway and I'd like your response to
this is that
I mean the folks on the board are Dennis
and
they're not necessarily in a position to
operate in effect this whole
administrative structure
and um I'm wondering if you know if you
agree to that and
I sort of had a vision and I don't know
I wasn't around when oplc was originally
created but
it would seem that uh you know any fixed
requirements should be handled by oplc
and things should only be brought to the
board if there's something that really
requires the Judgment of a practicing
dentist and and that would I would think
would greatly reduce the workload of the
board and you know take some of that
stuff off your shoulders I mean what do
you think about that
so I think the issue is
the reason we have so many observations
is the lack of administrative support
that the board has had in the last four
to five years
we've had meetings and hearings without
having a board counsel
even when we would ask for a board
Council to be present they could not doj
could not support Supply us one
once oplc was created obviously it was
created all the rules for oplc were not
in place there is no like even the audit
committee has said that the board should
have a written agreement regarding how
oplc would would satisfy administrative
functions and are always pushback is the
only way we can have a written agreement
is if the board can enforce it right we
are dependent on the oplc for all our
administrative functions
and if the board has a written agreement
with the with oplc and if that does not
happen the board should be able to
enforce it I don't know how so there's
been discussion about should that be a
legislative process so I'm not sure when
you say things that can be given to oplc
yes the administrative functions are
already done by oplc
so we're still there it's just a matter
of resources whether the board gets the
resources via oplc or whether oplc gets
those resources that's that's the debate
so we we will be bringing forth a lot a
lot of bills which we would be asking
your support to to make sure that this
happens all this time and effort that's
been put in the audit we want to make
sure that the next round of board
members who come on have a clean slate
and know that okay operationally they're
working fine foreign
thank you madam chair okay so it it the
questions are all interesting but uh I
think there's kind of a disconnect in
terms of the reality of how this all
works first of all you're the board
you're in responsible for oversight for
suggesting legislation and so forth and
so on blessing certain things and so
forth but you don't in many cases except
for conducting hearings on some kind of
a misconduct uh or uh personal feeling
like alcoholism or something like that
you're not involved in the day-to-day
credentialing and so forth and so on
that's a an administrative function that
must be carried out by staff right how
many people
how many people do you have that are
doing the credentialing you're not doing
the credentialing yourself
it's being done by staff members right
and this the criticisms here are mostly
about inadequate oversight or proceeding
without sufficient uh legal Authority
and so forth but most of the work is
done by staff no yes and no so
the staff receives the application for
any licensure how many my first question
doctor how many staff do you have so we
have one administrator and One support
staff and I don't know how many oplc
would be able to answer how many people
process the applications that comes in
six
stop but I think there's a
there's a period of time in which opot
and the board have gone through a
transition the audit identified that the
board itself is not examining all
applications and that is that's the
intent I think that's what the intent is
of the statute is to have the Board
review all licensing applications but
they identified as licensing
applications are being reviewed by
advice and I think the open question
from a policy standpoint that you may
see in some legislation is whether or
not the board should be reviewing all
applications or whether or not that
should be a staff function I think
that's still
okay so then follow up my follow-up
question is uh do you you believe
Lindsay do you believe that you and the
the board together have adequate staff
to process all the things because if the
board is going to be reviewing things
either they're just looking over
something that the staff has already
done
that's what review means somebody's
already seen it the oversight person
looks at it again but they're not going
to do all the grunt work of seeing
whether this this document is there
whether it's up to date whether it's
factual or fictitious or whatever
but you have an adequate staff to do the
kind of work that audit is is uh
if you have an effective control design
process with effective policies and
procedures you probably don't need as
many actual staff on the ground to
actually process the application the
issue and I can talk about it when I
speak about PLC generally is that
there's been a complete lack of
consistent policy procedures like a hot
body approach to licensing not just with
board essential examiners with everybody
and that kind of chaos if you know
people automatically think I gotta I
gotta put more people at this I think we
need to look at the procedures and the
processes first before we're able to
assess how much we actually need it
I'm not suggesting that you need more
staff my question is do you have enough
staff to do the day-to-day procedures I
think she's answered the question as
well as she can but I'm I'm speaking to
the committee several a number of these
people have never done one of these
performance reviews before and this kind
of criticism sounds scathing uh but it
may be there may be a disconnect in
terms of what your actual function is as
a board as professional dentists or a
public member and what is nitty-gritty
of receiving applications
yes representative Schmidt one of the
problems is that when you have a mess
adding more people to it just makes a
bigger mess I'm not I'm not suggesting
you need more staff my question was do
you have adequate staff because if you
do then procedures are what are are what
are at fault or deficient not how many
people you have doing that
yes I am more more concerned actually
that the invest the complaints not so
much that some of them were dismissed as
not in your jurisdiction or whatever
that happens but I'm somewhat concerned
that you can't keep track of the
complaints
not anymore not not with the enforcement
now so now we get monthly updates so now
we have where our board administrator
has a list that okay this has been sent
out what has not come back in
thank you I'm glad to hear that
representative Gerhart
thank you madam chair
as far as complaints go are these public
information or this is all internal
uh the complaint itself comes in in the
non-public session but the hearing is
public so once it's once it's
investigated we find there is Merit to
it and there is a hearing then that
becomes a public thing
okay and then the discipline is public
yeah
all right thank you very much thank you
any other uh any other things you want
to tell us about that we need to know
uh I think you'll be hearing a lot from
us so stay tuned all right yes excuse me
representative Gould has a question sure
more common but I I just this is
extremely alarming and
dental health is really important and
the health of the people in our state is
got to be the focus and it seems like
I don't know I haven't really heard
a sincerity in the responsibility of the
board in the issues that have happened I
hope that that is a part of your process
and I I hope that you can express that
to the people in New Hampshire who need
you to ensure their safety the women and
the children who could be at risk from
the lack of oversight it's alarming
I I agree because even the report to the
board itself was alarming
and every single board member who sits
on the board their basic basic aim is
protection of the public so we look at
it numerous times everything that has
come up and because I said we have this
now as a standing agenda item we've
already started okay let's deal with the
sedation thing first that's the biggest
thing that that affects standard of care
that affects access to care then that
affects safety of the public so we had
this discussion this morning that our
priority is safety access to care
becomes a second priority but there
could be unintended consequences of
whatever we do but that's still our
primary job is safety of the public so
we do take that seriously no question
about it
of course so I've only been on the board
a year and a couple months
and I volunteer to get on the board for
Public Safety I've been practicing for
42 years
um unfortunately a lot of this stuff
happened before a lot of the board
members are there and it's going to give
us great Direction
but it's really tough to give up a day
at work and come in and work so hard
hours looking through all this stuff on
the weekends away from your family and
and be The Whipping Boy it really is
very tough and a lot of the board
members are getting very discouraged and
this is a voluntary thing and they all
have their heart in the right place they
all care about their patience so I just
want to leave you with that no we we
would definitely have safety in mind we
just would need resources to do what we
are tasked to do so that we can we also
want to go home feeling that we've
accomplished something rather than just
sit around the table so thank you for
your time that you put into it having
worked in child welfare I get it I get
the problems but take responsibility
show the public that you are going to
follow through and then you won't be The
Whipping Boy
absolutely yes thank you representative
true
thank you madam chair
could you tell me I I think I heard you
say you you meet like once a month
something like that
why are you meeting once a month and
when you do meet
what are you doing
there must be a reason somebody called
you're bored to meet or was it
do it every month so we're meeting once
a month to address either the complaints
that are coming through or the board
audit report or the new dentist or the
new hygienist or any other rule change
we're constantly working on rule changes
because we all know it takes a while you
initiate something today it takes almost
a year for it to come around so we're
we're meeting constantly to either make
things better or deal with anything
that's coming up
thank you representative Schmidt you had
another question I do so the one of the
things I'm most concerned about is the
repetitive statement that you're doing
things without statutory Authority
you're creating new entities you're
creating new procedures and so forth and
so on where you have no statutory
Authority that should be the concern
major concern of this committee uh so my
question is uh in those cases where that
has been criticized what are you doing
in terms of proposals to the legislature
for statutory Authority so what the
board committee is identifying the board
audit report is identifying as a
as a body that we've created without
having statutory Authority is the ASAC
these the sedation guideline committee
and that was stated on the board's rules
and that's why how it was created we
dissolved that once audit committee said
you should have a legislatively created
committee so that committee has been
dissolved for a long time now since the
time the board since the time the audit
committee has identified and the
legislation that the board is asking is
putting forth is to create that
committee through a legislative process
is there a bill to do so yeah it's in
the LSR stages yes it's in the it's in
the LSR stage it is basically
lsrs file it's a Senate bill okay so
thank you I'm sure we'll we'll be seeing
it once the Senate's through with it
thank you representative Aber
thank you madam chair just one last
question for you thank you for coming in
today thank you I would assume that you
have a list of closeouts and some sort
of plan what is your time frame to have
all of these complaints completely
closed out and reported back I don't
have a deadline as yet because we've
just started working on this starting
our first meeting today I would say it
will probably take five years before
we're ready
did you say five years to fix these
thank you
anyone else
yes representative Gerhard thank you
madam chair just want to thank you guys
for coming in thank you and um I can at
least assure you from my point of view I
I don't remember the old Seinfeld
episode but I have no anti-dentite
sentiments so thank you
thank you I I'd like to share one thing
as far as the timeline one of the things
that is something that none of us can
change is just getting the our bill in
front of the Senate we had to wait till
November I had to make phone calls to
get it placed and we were talking about
build some changes for the legislature
for different things and we now we have
to wait till next November so the
legislative process is all-encompassing
as you guys know for us and that's why
he said five years is because it's taken
us a while we're not familiar with
legislative part and getting bills you
know uh into the Senate and we're
working hard to do that but we've got
two bills in and there's some other ones
we'd like to get in we're gonna have to
wait till next November representative
blackis thank you
um May I understand trying to get
everything resolved can take a while but
uh Courtney the audit report there's a
number of things you're doing without
statutory Authority and ad hoc rules and
those are just not legal
and I'd like you to assure me that that
stuff is going to stop really darn quick
that already has
all of that the rules and the uh all
right thank you
glad to hear it representative a bear
if you were to put a percentage thank
you madam chair
if you were to put a percentage of the
inadequacies
that would be closed out what would that
percentage be you've read the report you
have you know in your minds you've met
with your board this was type November
7th by you guys after review of the
audit
so you've met with your team twice
what percentage will be closed out
without additional legislation
if you see most of the recommendations
are to have legislative changes
once the legislative changes go in we
would have to write rules about it
because we don't know when the
legislation is proposed it goes in one
way and comes out the other way so I
don't know what's going to happen
but we are hoping that the rules part
would be done sooner than the
legislative part we would probably aim
to do 100 or whatever can be done
through rules that do it sooner than
later
yes thank you representative Simon has a
question
thank you so much
um recognizing that the board
changes frequently and you guys are
inheriting a great deal of uh the issues
that you're facing when it comes to
interfacing with us and the legislation
component of it are you basically
relying on oplc to keep you abreast of
legislative changes and updates that you
need to comply with or do you have your
own systems for that no so we rely on
oplc that's one of the points we have we
only find out about legislation that has
been enacted that's going to affect the
practice of Dentistry later
so we we don't even know that we could
have come and offered if we knew there
was a legislation pending and we had a
thought we could have come and offered
testimony to that but sometimes we only
find I shouldn't say sometimes 100 of
the time we only find out once it's gone
through so we rely totally on oplc now
the oplc sends us every month or every
six weeks we get a report of okay this
is the pending legislation that's coming
up but in the past that was not the case
yeah oh excellent follow-up thank you
madam chair um yeah I just wanted to
mention that because I'm assuming moving
forward that you guys will keep much
closer abreast of this stuff and make
the changes and I would be more
concerned that you went straight from
this point forward than that you had
gone this way before just from an
informational standpoint thank you thank
you yes
foreign
ER you have a final question
yes I do have one final question is for
the auditing team as to their opinion of
that percentage
that could be fixed without legislation
this is a pretty thick binder thank you
and it is my final question Madam chair
um
all right excellent uh
thank you very much for for showing up
and taking our questions
I would appreciate it if you could send
us after your board meeting what your
progress is that from that the minutes
from that section of the of the board
meeting or even just the whole set and
we'll clip it because we are concerned
and we know you're working on it we just
like to let you know that somebody's
looking at your progress so can I just
voice say one thing to this gentleman
yes
so since we have stopped asex
we're dead in the water
we have not been able to inspect any
anesthesia a facility or provider
to me that seems extremely dangerous
and we are literally dead in the water
we cannot do any inspections or anything
else without this per going forward
so
I realize what you're saying but what's
happened in the interim is there and I'm
very right now very sensitive to the
general anesthesia in the dental office
that is at a standstill right now
just so you know there's no inspections
being done and none of the people that
are providing and are being inspected uh
that's interesting
I don't understand does the board have
the authority to
to the board has the authority to
supervise the practice of Dentistry
correct
do you need specific legislative
authority to deal with
it the ad hoc committee is what took
they took that away from us well I
understand they took away the committee
but doesn't don't you have you the board
as a whole have that responsibility
already
so then it may be harder to do I'm sure
so the Asic committee was the committee
that was inspecting the dental offices
once the asec was disbanded
there was we were told that there should
be a RFA floated out to hire independent
investigators who would go out and
conduct those investigations
that took a while to be done that was
done
the investigators have been hired
but now oplc is writing rules for their
procedures about how will the submit
paper work how will they they get paid
so that is taking time everything takes
time and that's the situation we are in
now that okay we can't do what we were
doing
and so it's an unintended consequence
not that somebody intended it to happen
that way but that's an unintended
consequence until the time those that
rule is not in place they can't go out
and do the inspection I may interpret it
you do have the responsibility and you
accept it you are just working out the
details of how to accomplish it correct
we just we're not there yet but that's
what's happening
of course the things always take longer
than planned it's
anyone else
all right we will uh thank you again and
we will appreciate getting your uh your
reports on how you're doing on this
because we'll make sure it comes through
okay thank you thank you
thank you committee
all right
it's right it's your turn
uh good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee for the record I'm Lindsey
Corney I'm the executive director of The
Office of professional Ace insurance
certification
um I thought I'd just start by giving
kind of a bird's-eye view of my
perspective on the agency for those of
you who are not familiar with the agency
uh the agency was created in 2015 for
the Budget Trailer
um and I am the fifth executive director
of the agency that in and of itself has
certainly created some turmoil I think
over the years and has certainly not
helped the situation
but generally speaking occupational
licensure in New Hampshire has
historically been managed by independent
regulatory bodies or boards
before 2015 all of all of these boards
uh well
I'm just going to speak very generally
all of the boards operated independently
kind of typically all over Concord
um often in their own lease space with
their own staff the staff reported
directly to these boards who may or may
not have convened a monthly meeting some
boards don't meet monthly some boards
meet quarterly some words meet once a
year some you know you can't ever get
them to meet so
um in any event uh
it it was not
um
it was not a welcomed event I'll just
put that way when oplc was created at
least from the regulatory side that's my
perspective is that particularly on the
health side boards and most importantly
the staff were not thrilled about being
lumped together under one umbrella
agency and if you recall that year that
year the budget was passed in September
retroactive to July so sometime in
December everybody was supposed to be in
the same building together and it was
chaos
just from a staffing standpoint as well
as
people did not understand what the oplc
was supposed to be doing versus what the
boards were supposed to be doing
and they really lacked a clear
management
um
structure as well as internal controls
of course so for many years and by many
I mean about four or five they continue
to do what they continue to do the staff
all worked together with their
individual boards there were no changes
a few changes in terms of oplc having
you know two division directors and
executive director we had one one
attorney throughout the agency for all
50-ish boards at the time
and
um really not a lot changed in 2019 I
started I had the health division
and
um that had 34 boards including the
board of dental examiners I became
interim Ed in February of 2020 right
around the time that obviously covet
happened
but in early 2020 you know it took us
about six months to really understand
that
um that that the place was not working
well obviously the audit team had
identified numerous issues throughout
several audits of things that just
weren't working well namely the fact
that there weren't any internal controls
from my perspective it was hard to
assess whether boards particularly staff
were performing
um well there was no data
there were you know I mean I could tell
you nightmares there were checks being
left in drawers I mean it
there are a lot of bad things that were
not that were happening
um so uh working with the governor's
office we decided to do an internal
restructuring of the staff right around
the time of covid
so I tell you all of this so that you
understand that there with oplc and the
boards have been through a lot of
transition
we are not the same agency that we were
even at the time at the time period that
the audit is intended to address
and there has been a significant lack of
consensus I think across the years over
what oplc's role should be versus what
the board's rules should be and I think
that lack of clarity has certainly
contributed to some of the problems
identified in the audit
um but what are we going to do to
address uh the audit findings and I
apologize I have my phone here because I
was at a medical appointment all evening
so I didn't have time to print it plus
I'm told there's a toner shortage so
trying to be
economical
um
but in any event what we've done is we
have a strategic plan which I'll forward
all of you which really is intended to
address all of these audit findings in
addition to all of the other audit
findings and really fix a lot of the
major problems impacting oplc and the
boards because what you've seen in the
Dental Board audit you would see in
every other audit of every other board I
mean I can they they are not unique and
I think part of that is because they are
experts in their fields they're not
expert regulators and I think as time
has gone on and as administration of an
agency has become more complex we are
asking a lot of our experts in the
fields and those things really should be
performed by oplc pursuant to rules and
regulations and policies and procedures
so our primary one of the primary
findings obviously who is a complete
lack of internal controls which I I 100
percent concur with
um and so that is definitely our
strategic goal our first strategic goal
is to fulfill our statutory regular
regulatory requirements and some of the
strategies that we're utilizing is first
we created a position of internal
controls and contracts administrator
um who who is essentially at first just
inventorying all of the requirements
that we have to meet in order to comply
with the audit recommendations for all
of the audits dating back to I think
it's 2012 we have outstanding audits
um and she is going to be utilizing the
guideline established by Das Department
of admin services in order to
um
to
document our progress and help us put
into place a plan in order to meet the
recommendations
um but what we're doing now is
inventorying all statutory and
regulatory requirements and
um so far we've done it for a handful of
boards and I can tell you we have not
been doing everything that we need to be
doing
um and so we're going through each one
of the boards in order to First identify
what are the statutory requirements
um do we have rules in place that
Implement those statutory requirements
and do we have policies and procedures
um and so that's what we're doing and I
estimate across the agency
it will likely take us through 2024. I'm
really trying to do it as expeditiously
as possible because at the same time
we're working on a procurement of a new
licensing portal and I want to make sure
what goes in is is is accurate and that
we're not putting items or requirements
into the new licensing portal that's not
actually required okay excuse me we have
a question yeah let's do it
thank you madam chair I didn't want to
interrupt
um I just recall
going through the report I saw a few
instances where the board stated or I'm
sorry where the auditor stated that the
board needed more public members and I
recall
over the pandemic particularly you
testifying that many boards were having
that difficulty and I was just curious
if that has eased any have you seen more
people from the public being willing to
serve on this and other boards I think
we've seen greater increase in the
number of professionals seeking board
membership because we've changed our
process for um
trying to Market uh in a team but public
members are often difficult to find
because our the base the people that we
have to communicate with are
professionals
um so we rely often on Word of Mouth and
we have not seen an increase in the
interest in public participation
unfortunately yes I do hope uh director
that while you're looking at all these
requirements if you find a bunch of them
that have not been implemented for years
you suggest we get rid of them oh of
course thank you because I'm sure there
are some representative Fitzpatrick
um please please uh
bear with a new one new person here does
your office handle licensure for all of
the medical professions from Physicians
Department pardon me nurses yes we have
all of them with the exception of EMTs
that's with Department of Safety
there is health facility licensure
that's with Department of Health and
Human Services but for the most part we
have all of them and did I understand
that I heard earlier you have a staff of
five no that's just for the group that
Dental's in so right now
um we have 20 24 licensing staff I have
several open positions because I just
created new temporary positions
um we have a total authorized Workforce
of 126. thank you
so we're working on inventorying
requirements and that's that's the
initial stage and we're we're taking it
in chunks because of our need to prepare
a new licensing portal so we're really
focusing on both the renewal and the
initial licensure requirements trying to
get that inventoried prior to the
inventory of other requirements but that
is our focus and I anticipate it'll take
a couple of years just because it it's a
lot of work and unfortunately
um because unfortunately or fortunately
because I want to get it accurate I have
our attorneys working on doing that
initial assessment as to what's required
and what's not required because a lot of
the issues that have
um that exist are because
people didn't know any better and they
just created processes or they
interpreted the law incorrectly and they
just created a procedure or did
something and so on so we're relying on
our legal staff to do that initial
inventory
um to determine what we have to do and
what we don't have to do
so our second strategic goal is to
enhance customer service
obviously I consider that to fall within
the scope of what we're supposed to be
doing as a state agency and our Focus
here is to really procure new licensing
solution that will enable customer
service and I think what this gets to is
it all it's all intertwined so we need
to have internal controls in place to
ensure that we are asking people to to
perform tasks that they are required to
perform in order to obtain a license and
for example I personally just
inventoried uh the Board of Medicine
requirements licensure requirements I
can tell you
um there was that was a 27 step process
and
[Music]
that took almost a year for a physician
to get licensed
um they were asking for over 50 percent
of the requirements were not called for
in statute or rule so we got rid of that
we got it down to five steps and with
documented policies and procedures now
we're seeing applications go through in
a reasonable time frame of what's
required by 541 a so that's great but
we're going to be working with doit we
received some marpa funding in order to
procure a new licensing solution
um that'll that'll hope that will I
think address some of the I.T concerns
particularly the auditing capabilities
that you may notice in the report
that's an Enterprise solution that was
prepared by doit so you we will see that
on the horizon over the next
um the next year or so we'll be
implementing a new licensing solution
excuse me
um you say you're doing it board by
board essentially yes
could I ask what your priority is or how
you're choosing which ones to do next
yes
um we are prioritizing based on impact
to the public
so
um for example physician licensure has
been taking upwards of a year we have a
large number of physician applications
given the workforce issues we decided to
focus on physician I personally focus on
physician licensure I have somebody else
working on nursing licensure and then
I'm separately working on funeral
because well that doesn't impact the
public
I think Steve would have a field day
over here with that one so we're trying
to get ahead of that situation and make
sure that um they're following the rules
but it's generally
the impact to the public okay I hope the
board of mental health practice is high
on the list because I remember we you
were you saying that a large percentage
of their licenses are emergency licenses
um Madam chair can you uh could you
please repeat what you said just
previously which one was a total mess
you said once total Mexican have a field
day well what was that uh there was the
board of registration of funeral
directors and embalmers and they are um
they're they're collaborating with us
they're coming to the table
um one of the issues that we identified
was that they don't have a renewal
application so in the past in order to
renew a board member would just call
somebody
and go and do an inspection and
oftentimes their license had already
expired but it was fine because the
board member couldn't get to it and the
board member was collecting the money
and then holding on to them I mean so
we're remedying those issues but those
are the issues that we're finding when
we're conducting this inventory both of
Statute rule but also existing process
and I do want to mention that
unlike creating other agencies where you
can start fresh
creating oplc was had a different
challenge in the sense that we inherited
a lot of workflows and the staff at
times were hostile to having oversight
and there was some information hoarding
going on so we we
um you know we asked the questions and
we asked the questions again and then
maybe on the fifth time we actually
understand what's actually going on so
that is part of the challenge but I will
say that we've turned the staff over
which has been pretty positive
um about 80 percent since I started and
it and everybody's you know very excited
to
um to really comply with the law which
is the goal right so
laughs
senator blackis of that neighbor
thank you um
so I can kind of see how you got where
you are
um I wasn't involved you know when oplc
got created and I have to admit I have
not read all the statutes on this
um
but let me Express kind of my vision of
where it should end up and tell me if
this is in fact what you're trying to do
and that is that I mean all the
processing applications for new things
and renewals and reports of complaints
and all that we go through oplc and I
would think you'd have staff working for
oplc that would you know package up a
set of agenda items for a board only for
the decisions that need the
professionals expertise and that any
licensing renewal requirements which are
laid out clearly in statute and don't
require that kind of analysis would
happen automatically and that the only
thing the licensing boards would do
would be to be presented with these
decisions to make that require their
expertise and maybe you know do planning
for as the profession changes and you
know what might be needed in the future
is that reasonable or am I off base
yes that's precisely what I think the
difference in rules should be I would
like the board members to spend more
time engaging in forward-thinking policy
analysis as opposed to the day-to-day
stuff that is required of them by
Statute additionally my position is that
licensing should should not contain
subjective elements you know they're
always going to be those one-offs with
criminal history checks that requires
judgment that certainly Beyond a matrix
you know the board can take a look at
that but from a Workforce standpoint we
we just can't wait you know 30 60 days
for people to convene meetings so that
structure doesn't make sense
thank you madam chair thank you for
being here
my question is that
you have a number of boards that you are
reviewing and looking at as a result of
this one audit is that correct I
wouldn't say it's a result of the one
audit I would say that the audit has
helped inform
um provide a path forward but to be
honest with you a lot of the issues that
were identified were issues that we
already had already identified and were
already working on
um this is just providing us with a
clear roadmap
understood follow-on question
the um
just more of a comment hearing that
we're creating positions we're getting
temporary attorney help this will be a
cost to the taxpayers for something that
should have been
done all along is that correct no oplc
is self-funded by licensure fees so we
don't rely on the general fund or taxes
and we're required to spend our our
funding on licensure you know agency
activities we have not
um we have been able to utilize existing
funds historically we've lapsed a
substantial sum to the general fund so
I'm creating these additional temporary
positions did not impact anything other
than our lapse to the general fund
I was just confused by the arpa thank
you
Madam chair thank you now this if this
is totally outside I'm just ignorant of
this I'm concerned I know some nurses
and I know doctors were put under
pressure not to prescribe certain
treatments and all that and the boards
came after them and now we're hearing
that well I'm hearing at least that the
boards have some issues to begin with
internally is there anything to check
the power of the boards as far as you're
concerned or their decisions are gold
and then everything else is
do you follow so yes I well I think we
are both independent agencies
um there's a question I'm I'm waiting on
a legal opinion for there's one part of
our RSA that talks about supervision and
rulemaking activities but beyond that
um we are just Independent Regulatory
Agencies but we're both subject to
oversight legal oversight of doj and one
of the things that we've done is ensure
that an attorney is present in every
board meeting because we'd rather
proactively prevent things from
going the wrong way rather than cleaning
up a mess and so our expectation is that
if those concerns arose that
um that the Attorney General's office
would provide that oversight that's the
only mechanism that I'm aware of for
oversight of either agency all right
thank you well in some cases the scope
government what they can do and can't do
so yes the scope of practice what they
could do and can't do the find it fine
interpretation you're talking about
though is not something that probably
I assume uh correct me if I'm wrong but
ultimately if somebody has a dispute
with what the board's doing it's a
matter of taking them to court
right yes
um you can always appeal to the Supreme
Court if you have an adverse decision or
certainly seek a declaratory ruling or
excellent
um so then our third strategic goal and
again I'll circulate this as well as our
annual report I think there was a
question earlier about the number of
complaints that had gone to adjudication
that's captured on our annual report so
I'll circulate that as well but our
third strategical would be to increase
licensure portability
and I wanted to highlight because we're
we're talking about the audit is that we
are looking to collaborate with and
assist boards to reduce and streamline
regulations
a couple of boards come to mind not
necessarily Dental but where there's
just a lot of regulations and it's very
difficult I think even for attorneys to
navigate through so it's not necessarily
what's written but how it's written
um that we're we're hoping to
collaborate with the boards on and in
particular to help them redraft all of
their rules back in the day a lot of the
rules were drafted by their staff who
may have been you know mid label labor
grade level person and and or board
member and maybe there's a better way to
articulate what they're looking to do
and then finally for our fourth
strategic goal is we'd like to help the
boards promote public protection and we
are we have been trying to procure an
enforcement case management system to
track enforcement Trends promote timely
processing of Enforcement cases and
ensure consistent consistency and
outcome since I started in 2019 we have
a path forward we're going to work that
into our procurement of our licensing
portal so that all information is
captured in the same database the goal
being that obviously
it's completely unacceptable for an
agency to lose track of cases that is
the sole purpose really of a regulatory
board is to promote public protection
and respond to complaints so we have it
we have a system in place now but it's
quite rudimentary with our Excel
spreadsheet so we'd like to migrate to
something that allows for a little bit
more robust analysis so that the boards
can see trend you know if they are
seeing Trends in let's say opioid
prescription
are too high or something to that effect
then maybe they can be proactive about
continuing education and really be
proactive instead of reactive in their
regulation
so again I expect the internal controls
piece to take up approximately two years
through 2024 at least on the licensing
side because we're hoping to have
our system migrated at that point in
time and therefore when we need to have
internal controls in place but it's
going to be an ongoing process of really
evaluating conducting risk assessments
making sure that we have the appropriate
staff in place
and I think you know if we had adequate
internal controls in place we probably
could reduce the size of our staff I
think the the issue that we have right
now is just that we don't have one
streamlined approach and that's that's
our goal so with that I'm happy to
answer any questions you may have
regarding the oplc the audit or anything
else
all right last one let's just uh thank
you madam chair you said you want to
reduce the size of your staff
I didn't say I wanted to well it could
be done I said I yes I just want to be
clear okay so the staff is paid for by
licensing fees yes so that would re that
would be a reduction licensing fee so
that money would go elsewhere for it
could be reallocated
um it depends on a lot of our staff are
performing very basic manual you know
data entry for example
um
so there are some things that we're
exploring software robots that sort of
thing that that you know ensure 100
accuracy that actually would be so there
there are you know and obviously this
would be done through attrition but as
you all know that it's very difficult
right now for the state to find um
individuals well interested in working
for the state every agency has about a
20 vacancy rate so if we can fill those
gaps uh with technology and streamline
processes and procedures
and I'll give you this example
um so for complaints we just oplc just
promulgated a set of rules to govern the
administration of complaints
prior to that every board had their own
set of rules and they were all different
and so the three attorneys that
litigated before all of those boards had
to know 50 something sets of rules and
that obviously takes them a lot more
time so by streamlining that process we
could reduce administrative burden we
may not need to hire a fourth attorney
for example because they're not focusing
on that administrative task thank you
representative thank you madam chair is
it not true that a lot of your staff
would be shared between boards so that
you would particularly in the health
field so that if
you you would not need an extra staff
person for the Dental Board perhaps they
might be needed on the nursing board
yes all of our staffers shared
previously they were not and um we felt
that was uh
you know we would have some boards were
new in let's say June
um in August the staff would be
twiddling their thumbs meanwhile the
people renewing nursing would be you
know running around trying to get things
done we didn't find that to be the best
use of resources so all staff are shared
so that we can make sure that people are
being productive but we're meeting the
needs of but certainly yes
all right
yes representative Gould
thank you madam chair
I had a question regarding about what
percentage of complaints that come in
would you say are for abuse of clients
not many I would say we typically see
that more in the mental health uh
category and it's usually boundaries
issues sexual related conduct we also
see that in massage therapy actually
quite frequently
um
and occasionally with body art but those
um Dr coachar is absolutely correct that
for dental complaints it's often you
know disputes between patient and um
like contract disputes
okay thank you so if
in the case there was an Abu oh
follow-up
I'm new I'm learning the process here uh
in the in the case there was an abuse
complaint
whether it was with the dental border
other aspects of your office
if what would happen in the event you
had to wait
a month
I heard you talk about the concern and
that was my concern when we when we were
hearing but I'm a hammer I worked in
abuse and neglect so that's why I'm
asking these questions thank you yes
thank you for the question so I would I
during the audit period
um that was surveyed there was not a
good process for review of complaints
and investigations Dr coachar touched
upon that it was done through doj I
would like to say that our process has
significantly improved we have the
division of enforcement at oplc that
handles all of these and per the new
rules that were in place when we receive
a complaint we look at it the same day
and if it's something alleging abuse or
neglect it's immediately flagged as a
potential emergency our staff conduct
um
a mini investigation just to
substantiate the allegation often within
24 hours and if it is deemed to be
substantiated there are all you know
they send a memo to the board admin who
gets on the phone with the board chair
who calls an emergency meeting which can
be conducted pursuant to 90 when I I
would say that emergency meetings occur
most often in nursing with the diversion
all right well thank you very much I
think you've managed to exhaust us
Excellence knowledge thank you we
appreciate you resting up to attack you
in the later meetings I look forward to
it
um and also if any of you have questions
or would like to know more I'll
circulate my contact information feel
free to reach out to me directly thank
you I appreciate your time thank you yes
yes we will be uh seeing uh director
all right
Madam chair yes yes I don't know if you
think this is the appropriate time but
um perhaps you and representative
Schmidt could uh give particularly the
new members a little overview of the
administrative rules process and how
long it can take
uh longer than most sensible people
think it ought to as the usual answer
the thing is we we as a legislature
delegate to many of our agencies our
lawmaking
Authority by telling them to write rules
which have the effect of law
it turns out that what when we think of
it we think that yes we'll tell you what
the requirements are and you'll fill out
the petty fogging little details needed
to do it but sometimes
we leave them a lot of scope and they
get creative
the rules when written are reviewed by
the administrative rules office which is
a set of attorneys which verifies that
they do not exceed their
um their authority to write rules and
that they comply with the rule writing
process which is exhaustively detailed
in RSA 541a
you can read it sometime if you have
insomnia
all rules are then go before a committee
that is a joint legislative committee on
administrative rules
which looks at all the rules and
determines that they are not only
legal
don't cost too much and are in the
it's a
exhaustive process but it needs to be
done because as I said it's Our
obligation to make the laws and when we
delegate it we have to
oversee the people who are who are
making it on our behalf
um
so the that's the gel car meets it has
10 members five Senators five
representatives and the number of
alternates it meets every month in this
room usually on Fridays
and it looks looks at these these rules
and normally approves them
the rules can be
objected to but only on the grounds that
they exceed their Authority
cost too much
or are not in the public interest I
think that's the main one right Peter we
say the two primary things for the cost
aspect of the public interest are
they're all there but that that show
them the two main criteria pillars are
can exceed legislative Authority
in other words they can't go off on
their own just didn't decide whatever
they would like to do has to be to
implement the statute and the second
thing is it can cannot be contrary to
legislative intent
yes so so we will We that committee
looks at the rules and if they believe
it does not meet legislative intent they
can object to it
which will either induce the agency to
make a change
or if they don't want to make a change
it means they do not
have the
uh they have the burden of proof of
proving that the rule is worthwhile
rather than having it being assumed that
they're correct
uh if it's really objected to
that committee can bring forth a
resolution to to
the house usually first and ban the rule
from going and going into effect
so yeah I think you have to give at
least an example of what you're talking
about okay it's kind of vague yes so we
had a we had a smoking ban
for bars and restaurants
10 years ago okay
it was recognized by the agency that was
going to report to this
that if you didn't have any sanction
for a violation it was going to be
ignored if that's was going to be
ignored so the the agency put in a 50
fine
okay but there was no legislative
Authority for a fight and so that
particular thing was objected to by the
gel car an agency said we realize we
don't have any Authority but if you
don't you don't have a hammer they're
just going to ignore the statue okay so
the uh went through the
the policy committee which proceeded to
authorize changed the law to give them
the authority to put in the
administrative funds no that's an
example of overreach
um
Authority and so the committee said no
we object and the agency said we
understand we don't have any authority
to look at it don't work otherwise yeah
generally the jail car objects once or
twice a year to a rule it's not common
more more commonly we we talk about and
say we don't like this and and Bully the
agency into making the changes we want
that's
um it's
but when we are I the one that I
remember was
uh the map we had a state malpractice
insurance fund
that the insurance department decided
was unnecessary and they decided to
lapse a
several hundred million dollars back to
the general fund
which was in dire need at that point of
course
and so they wrote a rule to do so uh the
gel Cara said well you can't do that
it's not the general fund's money
because it was collected by uh
insurance payments by all of the doctors
in question so we objected to it and the
it went to the legislature and the it
was upheld they and the money was in
fact returned to the people who'd paid
into the insurance
but that was a
we do give refunds in fact that's uh
something that we noticed the last time
is that the veterinary it was the
veterinary board had been their rules
had expired and they can't enforce a fee
if it's they can't enforce a rule if it
has expired so they are in the process
of sending back the registration fees
for the people
who sent them in during the period the
rules were expired
so that's an unusual thing but it
happens all right
okay good I'll stop talking
thank you all and for showing up on a
Monday we will uh
have our first hearings on Wednesday and
then some on Thursday so I'll see you
then
foreign